mais bien chers aux abonnés
pardonnez-moi car j'ai péché
j'ai imaginé m'en sortir avec ce
débunkage
et bordel que j'en ai pris plein mon cul
oui j'enregistre cette introduction à la
fin de mon débat de mon enregistrement
parce que je m'attendais pas j'attendais
pas ce qu'il y a ce produit je pensais
que ça allait être simple rapide et
amusant ça a été long ça a été difficile
j'ai devenir fou j'ai pété un câble j'ai
pété un câble c'est de la folie je
m'attendais pas je je n'ai pas vu venir
je l'ai absolument pas vu venir et ça
m'est tombé dessus mais
mais alors comme un comme la mayonnaise
sur les hot-dogs quoi on n'est pas censé
mettre de la mayonnaise sur les hot-dogs
et là je non
vous n'êtes pas prêt vous n'êtes pas
prêt pour se débrencage et pénitence et
pourtant je vous assure je vous assure
que ça payait pas mis bref je suis juste
là pour vous prévenir je suis Julien du
futur et je vous préviens vous n'êtes
pas prêt je n'étais pas prêt personne
n'était prêt bienvenue dans le troisième
monde bienvenue dans la quatrième
dimension bienvenue dans la dans la
folie
bien je peux rien il y a rien ici ça
peut pas être décrit autrement bienvenue
dans un univers de fou je ne
je ne peux pas je n'ai pas les mots pour
expliquer ce que j'ai lu
je n'ai pas les mots mais bref pour
résumer dans ce truc là en gros ils vont
essayer de vous faire passer ça pour un
tronc d'arbre géant qui a été coupé au
sommet et en fait à tout pour tous les
géologues qui se respecte tout le monde
sait que ça ce sont des orgues basiques
d'une ça se voit à distance mais en plus
quand on fait les analyses quand on
récolte un échantillon de ce truc là et
qu'on le met sous l'âme microscopique
enfin qu'on en fait une lame
microscopique et qu'on la regarde au
microscope bien poli au microscope à
lumière polarisé on voit la structure
chimique
cristalline du basalte et il suffit de
la comparer à un basalte qui vient d'un
volcan directement pour constater qu'il
s'agit juste c'est juste de la lave en
fait c'est juste de la lave et ce que
vous voyez là c'est l'érosion qui a
sculpté un pilier de lave c'est rien de
plus c'est ni moins que ça donc ça ce
sont des orgues basiques à l'évidence on
sait comment ça se forme parce qu'il y a
des expériences qui ont été faites déjà
sur les orgues basaltiques donc là je
vous mets cet article en description
de l'univers de la géologie qui est un
très très bon article qui explique
pourquoi tout ça est faux mais et juste
c'est comme l'autre article là il part
dans une autre dimension complètement de
la réalité je veux juste vous mettre un
petit passage où voilà des expériences
de laboratoire ont été présentés en 2018
les scientifiques ont chauffé des
cylindres de basalte microcristallin
prélevés au pied du volcan islandais
effet déjà Yolo ou la cool
jusqu'à 980 degrés c'est la température
de son solidus à partir de laquelle il
commence à fondre ils ont ensuite laissé
refroidir tout en maintenant les deux
extrémités à une même distance ils ont
observé qu'entre 840 et 890 degrés la
concentration thermique du cylindre
provoque sa fracturation ce qui donne la
forme des orgues basaltiques la forme
hexagonale des orgues basaltiques ceci
étant dit toutes les orgues basaltiques
non pas cette forme hexagonale ça dépend
de la température à laquelle il se forme
vous voyez ce sont des coulées de lave
qui se forment les unes sur les autres
ça c'est visible à chiac en France ce
sont des coulées de lave et en fait il
faut que les couler de lave soit très
épaisses pour garder le basalte à une
certaine température pour que les orgues
basaltiques puissent se former donc en
fait tous les basaltes ne vont pas
ressembler à des orgues basaltiques
notamment ceux que vous voyez à la
surface il faut creuser pour atteindre
ces orgues basiques et creuser quand ils
sont en train de se former c'est juste
pas possible parce que c'est chaud par
définition donc on peut pas aller
observer la formation de ces orgues
bases Altics en direct mais par contre
une fois que l'érosion a fait son boulot
bah on voit les différentes coulées on
voit que le sommet de s'écouler est
complètement plat ce qui explique cette
structure ici plate au sommet et on voit
ensuite et on voit que ces orques se
sont formés par fracturation durant le
refroidissement du basal donc c'est
fracturation hexagonale là ces colonnes
c'est juste la fracturation du basalte
pendant son refroidissement plutôt lent
et du coup vous avez la structure
cristalline qui rentre en jeu dans la
fracturation du basalte c'est pour ça
qu'il se fracture pas de façon
complètement aléatoire donc je voulais
juste faire cette petite mise au point
avec vous avant qu'on commence parce que
vraiment vraiment vous êtes pas prêt et
je ne l'étais pas non plus
enjoy aujourd'hui on va parler des
arbres géants oui parce que il y a des
gens qui pensent que ça c'est un arbre
géant c'est un tronc d'arbre géant en
réalité il s'agit d'orgue basaltique les
orgues basiliques c'est un phénomène
très connu très répandu ça s'écrit comme
ça orgue basaltique voilà comme un orgue
comme un orgueil d'église il s'agit en
fait de lave en fusion et quand elle
refroidit elle forme des colonnades vous
savez un peu comme quand les un peu
comme corde l'argile sèche et sa forme
des genres de forme d'hexagone ou de
Pentagone ou des trucs comme ça ça forme
des formes géométriques en l'argile
sèche et ça fait des petites craquelures
de forme géométriques bah là pareil avec
le la lave en fait la lave qui refroidit
proche de la surface forment des orgues
basaltiques donc ces colonnades que vous
voyez là c'est tout à fait naturel et on
sait que c'est un phénomène naturel
parce que on peut l'observer en train de
se former
par exemple au Piton de la Fournaise
voyez donc il y a pas besoin d'aller
très très loin pour aller trouver des
orgues basaltiques ou python de la
Fournaise
évidemment j'ai pas écrit python comme
il fallait mais c'est pas grave
le Piton de la Fournaise voyez à la
Réunion vous avez tout un tas de
d'exemples ici d'orgues basaltique
qui sont visibles à la Réunion vous avez
une page Wikipédia dédiée aux orgues
basaltiques si vous souhaitez en savoir
plus
évidemment les orgues basaltiques c'est
un truc beaucoup parce que ah évidemment
le la nature ne forme pas de ligne
droite si on en croit les complotistes
les créationnistes de tout bord etc bah
si elles forment des orgues basaltiques
ces formes ces Orgeux basaltiques sont
souvent de forme géométriques comme sur
la chaussée des géants en Irlande mais
il y a des fois où c'est juste rond il y
a des fois où c'est patatoïdes donc bon
et l'explication la plus courante des
formations des orgues basiques est celle
de la contraction thermique lorsque le
basalte remonte depuis les profondeurs
de la croûte terrestre la masse solide
refroidie elle est encore chaude pas
encore structurée mais déjà solidifié
nous dit cet article dans The
conversecation écrit par Bernard Guy
enseignant chercheur aux mines
Saint-Étienne Institut des mines
c'est vraiment un truc que je vous
recommande alors the conte vers session
ou la conversation dans sa version
française c'est en fait c'est un truc
c'est un c'est une page web qui recense
des news entre autres scientifiques mais
aussi de la politique etc tout est sous
licence créative communs donc vous
pouvez copier coller sans aucune sans
aucun problème il y a aucun problème
avec ça
c'est et c'est écrit directement par les
chercheurs vous voyez l'auteur c'est
Bernard Guy c'est pas un journaliste qui
a écrit en fait the converse session
vous prend la main en tant que chercheur
je le sais parce que je suis auteur pour
the conversation
ça prend la main les les éditeurs
prennent la main les chercheurs les
aides à écrire l'article mais c'est
l'autre c'est le vraiment le
scientifique qui écrit l'article ou
l'expert en politique si vous regardez
les articles politiques etc etc donc the
converse session c'est un truc de c'est
un media grand public en fait c'est
supposé être un média grand public c'est
pas si connu que ça et là mais c'est
supposé être un média grand public écrit
par les chercheurs avec l'aide des
journalistes et non pas par les
journalistes avec l'aide des chercheurs
aide que les journalistes vont plus ou
moins ignorer quand ça arrive donc c'est
ça que j'aime beaucoup avec the
conversation allez voir the conversation
c'est écrit par les scientifiques pour
le grand public
donc ces orgues basaltiques finalement
ça résout déjà le problème c'est à dire
que bah non il y a c'est pas un arbre
géant ce truc là ça s'appelle les
divolstower ça se trouve en Amérique du
Nord vous les avez rencontrés dans
rencontre du troisième type par exemple
c'est la qui a lieu une des rencontres
avec les extraterrestres les Devils Star
Wars je crois même que c'est la
rencontre la grosse rencontre du film
c'est très connu c'est pas du tout un
secret le fait que ce sont des basalties
des orgues basaltiques c'est connu
depuis très très longtemps depuis qu'on
connaît les orgues basiques on sait que
les orgues de basaltiques sont d'origine
volcanique parce qu'on les voit se
former sur des volcans genre le Piton de
la Fournaise
bref la partie des bancages de cette
vidéo est d'ores et déjà fini merci au
revoir abonnez-vous
donc le reste de cette vidéo je pense ça
va être de lire cet article vous voyez
qu'il est très très long ça va être de
lire cet article et de rigoler par
Toutatice on va rigoler non ça vient de
top secret la vérité appartient à tous
mais pas dans ce magazine la vérité vous
l'aurez mais pas ici donc à la
découverte des arbres géants nous
mettent-ils avec des orgues basaltiques
notre monde est une illusion il y a eu
d'autres cycles il y a eu d'autres temps
il y a eu le temps des géants mais aussi
n'en est pas une preuve
qui a aussi d'autres titres quand même
il y a des tops secrets il y a des
titres vous allez voir qui sont super
qui sont super accrocheurs les
techniques du rêve lucide
la chiromancie une science millénaire
mutilation
mutilation l'étrange créature de la
forêt de Brocéliande il dit qu'il voit
pas le rapport d'aussi OVNI 1934-1945
rencontre avec les chasseurs de fantômes
chasseur de fantômes OVNI il dit qu'il
voit toujours pas le rapport
civilisation disparue lors du Gobi
parce qu'on peut pas parce que l'or
n'est pas un minerai qui peut exister
tout seul apparemment il faut une
civilisation disparue Bruce Lee les
secrets des anciens maîtres
c'est vrai que Bruce Lee Bruce Lee ça
remonte au moins un Milan
c'est les secrets millénaires des
anciens maîtres Bruce Lee Men in Black
les hommes en noir le phénomène des
Hartmann
ça
il y a des gens qui lisent ça il y a des
gens qui il y a des gens qui payent 7
euros pour lire ça c'est sorti quand
c'est sorti en mars 2017 c'est pas vieux
c'est février mars 2017 c'est pas vieux
du tout ça se vend au Canada en Belgique
Luxembourg enfin tous les pays
francophones c'est ouf c'est absolument
ouf que des gens lissent ça
mise en garde certains lecteurs
pourraient être décontenancés par les
informations véhiculées par ce dossier
les questions soulevées ici aussi
pertinentes soient-elles j'en doute
doivent donc être abordés avec beaucoup
de recul de la part du lecteur et
considéré comme des hypothèses de
travail et de réflexion il est donc pas
inutile de souligner que ces
informations sont à prendre avec la plus
extrême prudence
c'est la façon polie de vous expliquer
vous êtes sur le point de lire de la
merde
[Rires]
c'est une façon très très polie de vous
expliquer non mais j'ai écrit l'article
mais j'y crois pas j'en crois pas un mot
je sais que c'est des conneries mais que
voulez-vous il y a des auteurs faut bien
qu'ils mangent
[Rires]
comme le dirait Bruno Salomone comme le
dire à Bruno Salomone il y a des auteurs
il faut bien qu'ils mangent et voilà
donc bon j'ai écrit ça j'en suis pas
très fier mais bref c'est magnifique
c'est prodigieux de commencer un article
comme ça par ce qui est expliqué ici va
être de la merde voilà n'en croyez pas
un mot je vous en supplie mais voilà
ici repose la dignité la dignité
journalistique et surtout j'aimerais
comprendre une petite minute de silence
pour tous les gens qui ont acheté ça qui
ont payé ça 7 euros et il y a écrit
dessus c'est des conneries n'y croyez
pas
j'aimerais qu'on prenne une minute de
silence pour ces gens-là mettez sur
Pause et prenez une minute de silence
combien l'on fait combien on fait mettez
en commentaire combien l'on fait minute
de silence pour tous ces gens qui ont
payé 7 euros pour lire un truc qui
commence par ni croyez pas c'est des
conneries on commence donc à la
recherche des arbres géants nous avons
tous connu enfant ces vieilles histoires
de contes de fées plein de châteaux
peuplés de princesses et de dressés de
donjons ces histoires on nous les
racontait à l'école dans les petites
classes où nos parents nous lisaient à
la douce lumière d'une lampe de chevet
assis au bord de notre lit pour nous
endormir il s'agissait d'histoire où les
héros étaient des personnages
fantastiques qui vivaient dans un
environnement surdimensionné et où
régnait des géants si les auteurs de ces
vieux comptes glissés dans leur récit
une leçon morale exemplaire pleine de
bravos et de sentiments cheval reste
qu'en est-il du fond légendaire ces
histoires ont le sait qui est ont
s'inspire souvent des mythes d'autrefois
des vieux textes sanskrit avec des vieux
textes sanskrit mais aussi de la Bible
qui nous parle d'un temps où les géants
vivaient sur terre encore un endroit
l'endroit où on va prendre pour argent
comptant les textes de la Bible
c'est ces histoires d'arbres géants on
trouve ça à deux endroits on trouve ça
quand j'ai fait des j'ai quand même fait
un petit peu de recherche mais juste
vraiment pas beaucoup parce que ça
tenait pas debout plus de 15 secondes
vous avez vu c'est évident que c'est des
orques basiques mais bref ces histoires
d'arbres géant il y a que les
créationsnistes qui les reprennent parce
que ça prouve l'existence des géants et
si les arbres étaient géants c'est que
les gens étaient géants évidemment ça
coule de source je veux dire les arbres
géants n'existent que pour justifier
l'existence de Jean géants et il y a les
platistes mais alors ça les platistes
j'ai pas compris le rapport les
platistes kiffent ces histoires d'arbres
géants mais je comprends pas la logique
parce que je sais pas il y a des arbres
géants donc la terre est plate je
[Musique]
j'imagine que la logique c'est il y a
des arbres géants on nous cache la
vérité donc on nous ment donc la terre
est plate mais
j'ose espérer qu'on va nous l'expliquer
là dedans mais je vois pas le rapport
dans les contes de fées les géants ont
presque toujours en possession des
trésors technologiques ou des secrets
qu'ils gardent jalousement on se
souvient de Jacques et le haricot
magique c'est-à-dire au moins pour une
fois il cite leur source
après Jacques et le haricot magique je
sais pas si c'est scientifiquement
valide comme source mais au moins pour
une fois il cite leur source adapté par
le cinéma ou les héros grâce ou le héros
grâce à une simple graine parvient à
faire pousser un arbre géant en escalade
dans cet arbre il va vraiment nous
refaire toute l'histoire de Jacques le
haricot magique
cet arbre jusqu'au sommet qui atteint le
ciel Jacques découvre une terre inconnue
habité par un ogre au cours de cette
aventure épique il a réussi à lui voler
ses trésors Jacques est parfois comparé
avec le Jacques tueur de géant qui est
autant de rois Arthur utilisa la ruse
pour les vaincre reste à définir à
l'arrêt reste à définir la raison pour
laquelle ces géants sont toujours aussi
nuisibles en fait selon certains
chercheurs ces mythes certains
chercheurs
là par contre dès qu'il faut commencer à
toucher un petit peu à quelque chose de
sérieux c'est on
prenons indéfini et ça restera aussi
indéfini possible et certains chercheurs
alors est-ce que si c'est des chercheurs
au CNRS ça va mais alors si c'est des
chercheurs de veritudes là par contre
les fameux chercheurs de vérita du net
là par contre on vous dira pas lequel de
ces chercheurs on est censé citer à cet
endroit là c'est mythes qui passent pour
des histoires à dormir debout en
l'occurrence à faire dormir vos enfants
prendre les ressources dans une mémoire
collective gardienne d'une histoire
cachée de notre monde il s'agirait de
souvenir appartenant à l'inconscient
collectif et qui se manifesterait au
monde tout en finesse à oui oui ça c'est
ça c'est fin ça c'est fin comme du gros
sel dans une poivrière à moutarde pleine
de sucre j'ai envie de dire
parfois par l'intermédiaire de personnes
douées pour les contempler et les
retranscrire sous forme de fables en
usant de paraboles sous le voile de
conte pour enfant nous parlons du monde
qui autrefois étaient différents étaient
différents mais c'est pas une phrase
ça aurait dû être une virgule à la fin
de tout en finesse bon bref c'est
bizarrement écrit des histoires qui
commencent par il était une fois un
terme qui contrairement à ce qui peut
paraître établi clairement la réalité
des vagisseurs ont révélés tout au long
du récit
je vous invite à admirer le niveau de
logique dès l'introduction si ça
commence par il était une fois et non
pas il serait une fois alors ce sont des
faits
il y a des gens qui ont payé 7 euros je
pense que je vais je vais le rappeler
très souvent
que il y a des gens qui ont payé 7 euros
pour lire ça on cite Philippe Cadic il y
a j'ai vu marquer Philippe CALIC ne
salissez pas la mémoire de Philippe
Cadic par pitié grand maître de la
science-fiction devant l'éternel par
pitié non non je refuse
l'histoire disparue de la terre
resurgirait-elle dans l'esprit de
certains auteurs inspirés Philippe Cadic
célèbre auteur de science-fiction parle
de souvenirs récupérés certifiant que
ses œuvres fictionnelles étaient vraies
issues de rêves enfouis dans son
subconscient alors je sais pas s'il a lu
Philippe caddy qui avant de déclaire son
truc mais il y a quand même une de ces
histoires et il y a une de ses nouvelles
c'est dans le même livre que Blade
Runner dans le même recueil de nouvelles
que là où se trouve la nouvelle qui a
inspiré le film Blade Runner il y a une
histoire de castor qui parle
il porte un petit chapeau melon le papa
castor il y a une histoire de castor qui
parle
et c'est des souvenirs ça aussi ou
est-ce qu'ils étaient géants les castors
en plus c'est de la science-fiction
c'est à dire que c'est de la
science-fiction face à des souvenirs
donc par définition quelque chose du
passé qui ressurgirait du futur
tu aurais pu au moins prendre Tolkien
qui est à salir un auteur
un auteur admiré du grand public tu
aurais pu au moins prendre Tolkien voilà
quelqu'un qui a créé un monde de
d'héroïque fantasy et donc par
définition aspirée plutôt du passé
à la limite qui t'apprendre de la
science-fiction tu aurais pu prendre
Georges Lucas
qui qui fait dérouler son histoire dans
il y a très longtemps dans une galaxie
lointaine très lointaine mais pourquoi
prendre Philippe Cadic
je
[Musique]
comprends pas là il y a des décisions
narratives dans cette histoire de
d'arbre géant qui commence déjà à poser
des questions très sérieuses sur sur la
santé d'esprit des gens qui veulent bien
croire ces histoires
un monde fabuleux antérieuronaute peuplé
de géants et d'architecture grandiose
aurait-il été détruit au point qu'on en
est perdu non seulement le souvenir mais
aussi la trace
et surtout il aurait été détruit à tel
point que même qu'on arrive à retrouver
des dinosaures mais qu'on n'arrive pas à
retrouver aucune trace sérieuse de ces
géants
ça serait quand même assez ouf d'autant
que là quand il parle quand il parle de
ces géants millénaires bah c'est des
géants qui sont seulement millénaires
moi moi et mes thérapsi de 250 millions
d'années je t'avoue qu'avec tes géants
millénaires on n'est pas impressionné
très honnêtement
ça fait pas ça remonte à pas loin
quelques millénaires on devrait avoir
des traces de ça et s'il y a aucune
trace de ça c'est qu'il va peut-être
falloir envisager la possibilité que
éventuellement ça n'a jamais existé
si on retrouve pas de trace de ça mais
plein de traces d'autre chose qui sont
censés avoir le même âge qui n'ont pas
plus de raison d'avoir été préservées
que la première que les géants pourquoi
est-ce que éventuellement on
envisagerait pas l'idée que en fait les
histoires de géants c'est des conneries
point d'interrogation
il n'en resterait que le récit épique de
nos légendes il a quoi c'est une phrase
ça il n'en resterait que le récit épique
de nos légendes donc la trace des géants
certains chercheurs ont déjà évoqué
cette possibilité toujours des
chercheurs sera toujours pas si c'est
des chercheurs de vérita ou du CNRS je
me souviens de mon étonnement je me
souviens de mon étonnement donc je vous
raconte une anecdote personnelle qui n'a
aucune valeur de preuve je me souviens
de mon étonnement en lisant pour la
première fois l'hypothèse selon laquelle
certaine montagne et autres grands
rochers du monde ressemblaient en fait à
des cités vitrifiées appartenant à un
autre âge
et je me souviens certainement ne pas
avoir fait plus de recherches que ça
pour me rendre compte qu'en fait c'était
juste des cailloux un point c'est tout
Robert Charroux
un nom qui revient un peu souvent quand
il s'agit de bullshitus
bullshitus tartinus bien étalus sur ton
anus
en fait
Robert Charroux en fait mention avec
quelques arguments photographiques
des photos floues des photos floues on
appelle ça
dans l'un de ces livres un article dans
une revue oubliée a également retenu mon
attention sur ces fameuses cités et
forte respectifiées que Robert Charroux
décrivait la question qui demeure c'est
comment de tels ouvrages de roches et de
Pierre élevées ont-ils pu être pétrifiés
ou vitrifiés non la vraie question c'est
s'agit-il de véritables
citer pétrifiée et vitrifier ceci étant
dit on attend encore l'histoire des
arbres géants là on nous parle de cité
donc
publicité mensongère j'ai envie de dire
donc Harry Potter et l'alien magique le
chasseur de géant et le livre de Robert
Charroux
ah bah tenez là il le met des villes
Star Wars aux États-Unis a-t-elle
inspiré l'intrigue des films rencontre
du troisième type de Steven Spielberg et
si oui qu'est-ce qu'on en a à
pourquoi la Devil Star Wars aux
États-Unis a-t-elle inspiré toute
l'intrigue du film rencontre du
troisième type de Steven Spielberg
et une fois qu'on vous aura dit bah
parce que c'est marrant comme montagne
qu'est-ce que ça change
sérieusement c'est ah ouais mais c'est
un livre avec c'est un film où il y a
des extraterrestres comme par hasard
comme par hasard comme par hasard
certains chercheurs de vérité ah bah ça
y est là le le c'est bon le doute est
dissipé voilà c'est pas les chercheurs
CNRS c'était les autres
les chercheurs de veritudes les fameux
vous savez ceux qui cherchent sur
internet sur Google les chercheurs de
vérita sur Google et dans les tabloïdes
qui dans les années 70 chercher dans les
tableaux de bon marché les titres
racoleurs etc etc oh là là là là là
et c'est un penalty pour contre l'équipe
des géants hélas oh mais ça va être une
vraie raclée mon cher Jean mimi
certains chercheurs de vérité le mot est
lâché affirme sans autre forme de procès
ils affirment
on va pas on va pas chercher à avoir de
la subtilité ou employer du conditionnel
nous c'est il était une fois voilà donc
n'affirme que c'est vrai
donc c'est il était une fois une fille
qui avait des cheveux tellement longs
qu'on pouvait grimper tout en haut de la
tour en les escaladant ses cheveux c'est
vrai c'est la vérité
réponse c'est un documentaire voilà donc
tous les dessins animés Disney sont des
documentaires exactement
certains chercheurs de vérité affirment
que ce sont des géants qui ont édifié
ces monuments mais oui évidemment il y a
des gros cailloux ça peut être empilé
que par des gros gens rappelez-vous la
logique élémentaire on ne peut pas
soulever des gros cailloux si on n'est
pas un gros Jean on ne peut n'existe pas
de moyens de soulever des gros cailloux
quand on est un petit Jean je vous
présente ici la page de New tech new
Tech qui avait fait un débunkage de la
révélation des pyramides hilarant
je reviendrai très souvent à cette page
parce que dans cette page il y a une
vidéo où on voit une personne seule
absolument seule
déplacer des cailloux gigantesques juste
à la puissance de son intellect voilà je
vous mets le passage immédiatement on
voit cette personne juste avec juste
avec de l'ingéniosité en fait cette
personne seule déplace des gros rochers
vous voyez il a réussi à soulever cet
énorme
cet énorme monument de pierre là
gigantesque donc et tout ce qui fait en
fait c'est légèrement basculer le truc
d'un côté insérer une cale légèrement
basculer le truc de l'autre côté voilà
insérer une cale
et ainsi de suite
regardez là donc il bascule il insère
une cale bim
ensuite il bascule de l'autre côté il
insère une autre cale et ainsi de suite
et comme ça il va réussir à soulever le
truc le rocaillou le rocaillou que si on
est géant on peut pas le soulever il a
réussi à soulever le rocaillou pour le
mettre à une hauteur une hauteur qui
permet de recréer une sorte de stonage
voilà il a réussi à dresser aussi un
énorme un énorme pilier à lui tout seul
encore une fois juste à force d'ingénité
et juste avec du bois et de la corde
vous savez c'est aussi un des arguments
que l'on peut pas réussir à accomplir ce
genre de choses juste avec du bois et de
la corde et il arrive à faire ça
évidemment parfaitement niveau voilà
tout ça tout seul
donc ouais non l'argument faut être faut
forcément être un géant pour soulever
des rocaillous
faut forcément faut forcément être un
peu crédule pour s'imaginer que ça vaut
quelque chose
les mythes nous apportent en effet nous
rapporte en effet que des dieux géants
ont bâti des cité ainsi que des
forteresses et qu'il disposait à
l'époque de nombreuses armes redoutables
capables de faire fondre la roche
elle-même de la folie de la folie en
interrogeant quelques amis sur la
question des géants je me suis rendu
compte que la majorité d'entre eux était
enclin à accepter l'idée que leur
existence de leur existence dans une
primo histoire
lointaine et oubliée j'ai demandé à des
copains ils m'ont dit que j'avais raison
donc j'ai raison
mais oui la fameuse bulle la fameuse
bulle dans laquelle vous vous enfermez
vous savez forcément les gens qui sont
capables de vous contredire vous avez
coupé les ponts avec eux depuis
longtemps à part si c'est votre famille
éventuellement et que vous avez pas
d'autres choix que d'être pote avec eux
mais évidemment que si vous demandez à
votre bulle votre petite bulle de Jean
sélectionnés avec qui vous êtes capable
de bien vous entendre si vous leur
demandez s'ils sont d'accord avec vous
la probabilité et qu'ils ont et qui vont
probablement être d'accord avec vous
autrement il ferait pas partie de votre
bubulle
donc là on est sur l'argument de
popularité
bas de plafond
en dehors des monuments antiques
révélant de relevant de l'art du
gigantisme architectural et dont on
ignore encore le mode de fabrication et
de construction oui parce que les
monuments antiques dont on connaît les
secrets de fabrication ça par contre ils
font pas partie des théories
il y a que les monuments antiques dont
on connaît pas les secrets de
fabrication vous voyez genre les
pyramides les pyramides ça c'est un
monument antique dont on ne se connaît
pas le secret de fabrication enfin du
moins quand on est un chercheur de
veritudes et qu'on ferme suffisamment
les yeux en ignorant complètement et en
ce que disent les archéologues et en les
qualifiant de d'escrocs évidemment en
insultant les archéologues et en les
disant que ce sont des escrocs on arrive
suffisamment à ignorer comment les
pyramides ont été construites voilà on
arrive c'est bon c'est bon je vois rien
j'entends rien je veux rien comprendre
bon quand il s'agit de monument antique
genre le Colisée de Rome donc autrement
plus jeune je le conçois mais quand il
s'agit de monument antique genre le
Colisée de Rome dont on sait très bien
comment il a été construit où le
Parthénon quand c'est très bien comment
il a été construit là tout de suite ça
devient plus chiant effectivement ça
devient un peu plus chiant de construire
des théories bulgit autour de ça puis
alors quand on quitte l'Antiquité et
qu'on va sur des merveilles
architecturales autrement plus
compliquées à établir comme les comme
les cathédrales par exemple là-bas alors
là là c'est fini je veux dire on a on a
de la documentation qui nous dit
exactement comment on a fait je veux
dire comment voulez-vous établir une
théorie bullshit autour de ça non vaut
mieux retourner à des monuments antiques
vous voyez où là il y a pas de
documentation il y a pas plus de raison
de penser qu'une pyramide c'est-à-dire
un empilement de cailloux en triangle a
été fait par autre chose que des êtres
humains que les cathédrales je veux dire
les cathédrales comme je le dis c'est
hautement plus complexe qu'une pyramide
donc il y a pas plus de raison de penser
qu'une pyramide a été faite par autre
chose que des êtres humains que pour une
cathédrale mais pourtant comme il y a
comme on a perdu le mode d'emploi comme
les Égyptiens même les Égyptiens
eux-mêmes de Milan après à l'époque de
Cléopâtre on avait déjà perdu le mode
d'emploi donc comme on a perdu le mode
d'emploi
on a perdu la notice voilà comme ton
micro-ondes et Ben et ben on peut
établir là il y a un degré de liberté
qu'on peut dont on peut se permettre
tout ce qu'on veut et voilà c'est ça qui
est fantastique avec le complotisme et
le bullshit la bullshitosaurus Rex c'est
que dès qu'il y a dès qu'il y a un petit
vide quelque part on peut faire ce qu'on
veut et ça c'est bien c'est génial
donc bref les pyramides les chercheurs
de vérité estiment qu'il y a d'autres
indices attestant que la terre porte
effectivement les stigmates témoignants
de l'ouvrage des géants mais aussi d'un
environnement terrestre adapté à leur
mesure ah ça y est l'introduction les
grands arbres les grands arbres parce
que je rappelle on est à la page numéro
2 on a toujours pas parlé des grands
arbres il existe un peu partout sur
terre des formations rocheuses que les
géologues considèrent comme absolument
naturel alors je t'annonce tout de suite
si c'est des grands arbres même en
partant du principe que tu as raison
même en partant du principe que tu as
raison des grands arbres pétrifiés ça
reste naturel
je sais pas quelle est ta définition
d'artificiel
mais elle est fausse
si tu crois qu'un grand arbre pétrifié
c'est pas naturel
alors ta définition d'artificiel est
fausse et ta définition de naturel aussi
d'ailleurs donc fais attention les mots
ils ont un sens faut faire attention
c'est important 7 euros qu'ils ont payé
les gars 7 euros pour pour lire
quelqu'un qui dit que un arbre géant
pétrifié ce serait pas naturel
bref or peut-être que je fais un mauvais
procès peut-être que le reste de la
phrase est pas si bête que ça il existe
un peu partout sur terre des formations
rocheuses que les géologues considèrent
comme absolument naturel mais dont les
aspects structurels très particuliers
rappelle étrangement des formes qui nous
sont familières
étrange le mot étrange et lâché je pense
notamment à cette structure appelée
devilstower qui surplombe la vallée de
l'État du Wyoming aux États-Unis offrant
un panorama grandiose à la vue de tous
les visiteurs et voyageurs empruntant la
route mythique 66 ah il regardait plus
près avec l'esprit ouvert avec l'esprit
ouvert l'ouverture d'esprit
l'excuse la plus pathétique pour la
fermeture d'esprit c'est de dire garder
les spray ouvert
allez vous faire
je l'avale je le garde
j'ai horreur des gens qui appellent à
l'ouverture d'esprit ça me gave mais ça
me gave à chaque fois qu'on te dit
garder l'esprit ouvert c'est genre donc
les scientifiques sont fermés d'esprit
puisque encore une fois on s'oppose aux
chercheurs ça a été c'était la phrase du
dessus donc j'invente rien là
on s'oppose aux chercheurs en disant oui
mais nous on a l'esprit ouvert mais donc
t'as pas l'esprit ouvert c'est juste
c'est pas une poubelle ton esprit en
fait c'est ouvert mais comme une
poubelle reste ouverte pour accueillir
tout et n'importe quoi c'est pas
d'ouverture d'esprit ça l'ouverture
d'esprit c'est quand tu es ouvert à la
possibilité que oui ces formations
rocheuses seraient des orgues
basaltiques elles n'ont rien à voir avec
des arbres
là tu es fermé d'esprit tu es fermé
d'esprit à cette explication tu ne veux
pas entendre la vie des géologues le
fameux avis des géologues vous savez
ceux qui quand il s'agit de cailloux
savent de quoi il parle
vous savez c'est leur métier c'est leur
métier il dédient leur vie à ça c'est
leur métier c'est leur passion et
eux-mêmes ont appris des plus grands
c'est une tradition de géologie qui date
de plus de 200 ans
une tradition de pas s'arrêter à
l'explication à la con la plus simple
mais d'aller plus loin d'aller au fond
des choses d'aller voir le Piton de la
Fournaise pour constater que ce sont des
orgues basaltiques et que c'est la même
chose qu'à devilstower c'est vous qui
êtes fermé d'esprit c'est vous c'est pas
c'est pas les scientifiques c'est les
c'est les chercheurs de vérité quand on
leur montre la vérité ils détourne le
regard non j'ai pas vu j'ai pas vu je
veux pas savoir
tu veux pas savoir tu es fermé d'esprit
moi j'ouvre j'ouvre mes chakras la
possibilité que ce soit un arbre tu me
montres quoi des orgues basaltiques ah
bah je suis désolé mais là j'ai ouvert
mes chakras et tu m'as rien donné là tu
m'as rien donné
et vous
je pensais qu'on allait rigoler et puis
en fait non on rigole pas j'aurais dû
faire un des bunks et pénitence de ce
truc là j'aurais dû
je pense notamment à cette truc
structure appelé divolstower qui
surplombe blabla en y regardant le plus
près avec l'esprit ouvert entre grosses
guillemets l'esprit ouvert l'esprit
ouvert ça veut dire en acceptant que
j'ai déjà raison avec mon mon
explication d'arbre géant en gardant
l'esprit ouvert au fait que c'est moi
qui ai raison
cette montagne prétendument formée par
des roches ziggnées ressemblent à s'y
méprendre à la souche d'un arbre géant
pétrifié
alors prétendument formé par des roches
ziggnées donc
ignié qui est la tradition de IG news en
anglais qui veut dire roche d'origine
volcanique pas celtique donc il le sait
le gars en plus
le gars il le sait et il vous ment
aucun problème il est au courant le gars
que c'est des orgues basaltiques en plus
mais quoi mais quoi
tu le sais que c'est de la lave
et tu dis et donc il balance du jargon
parce que rush zinnier je veux dire il y
a un million de façons de traduire rush
ignié enfin Ignus rocks en anglais il y
a des millions de façons de le traduire
que le commun des mortels francophones
comprendra donc comme je le dis lave
magma basalte je sais que tous ces mots
sont pas exactement synonyme mais je
parle du comme pour le commun des
mortels évidemment je fais de la
vulgarisation quoi donc lave magma
basalte roche volcanique
tout ça c'est c'est globalement synonyme
de roche ziggnier et ça vous permet de
tout de suite communiquer l'idée que
l'origine est volcanique
et au lieu de ça l'auteur choisit
délibérément d'employés le terme
jargonneu et probablement un barbarisme
anglais mais qui suis-je pour juger de
ce qui est réellement à barbarisme
anglais
vu que j'en fais tout le temps donc il
choisit ce terme jargonneux et
probablement pas réellement français de
ignié et pourquoi il le choisit parce
que il n'y est personne connaît si vous
avez pas fait au moins
PSVT en terminale
et je crois que ça n'existe même plus
aujourd'hui ce PSVT en terminale mais
bref si vous n'avez pas fait au moins ce
PSVT en terminale quand vous étiez au
lycée il est probable que vous n'ayez
jamais jamais au grand jamais été exposé
au concept de chicnier levez la main
ceux qui ont été exposés
probablement les mêmes que ceux qui ont
fait une minute de silence tout seul
bref son apparence inhabituelle a donné
naissance à de nombreuses légendes ah
évidemment s'il y a des légendes c'est
super mystérieux si s'il y a des
légendes qui suis-je pour accepter
l'explication scientifique encore une
fois
d'ailleurs en 1977 la tour du diable fut
utilisée pour la scène finale du film
rencontre du troisième type de Steven
Spielberg et si ça c'est pas la preuve
qui a anguille sous roche mec
si ça c'est franchement
je pensais qu'il y avait un niveau zéro
au preuve à ce qui est ce qu'on pouvait
considérer comme une preuve mais là on
est en dessous là en Creuse on creuse là
on cherche du pétrole
du pétrole noir et bien sale
en interrogeant mes proches encore une
fois
en allant en allant poser des questions
aux gens qui ont de fortes probabilités
d'être d'accord avec moi sur cette
structure je me suis aperçu que quelques
incroyaillés qu'il s'agissait d'une
oeuvre imaginaire du réalisateur pour
son film comme l'a été le Big Thunder
Mountain à Disneyland conçu pour une
célèbre attraction de montagnes russes
où le rocher du parc des buts de
Chaumont à Paris ou encore comme le
grand rocher du zoo de Vincennes qui eux
sont totalement artificiel
elle était longue cette phrase donc on
vous montre une photo de Disneyland et
on vous montre des cailloux voilà le Red
Rock State Park et ça c'est bien je
suppose j'en sais rien et ça c'est censé
vous convaincre de quelque chose mais je
vois pas quoi Devil stauer au Wyoming
existe vraiment pour ceux qui en
douteraient encore il a été formulé un
certain nombre d'hypothèses sur cette
formation géologique hors norme je veux
bien le croire dans le milieu
scientifique officiel
les chercheurs de vérité
les villas contre les villas
scientifiques officiels les vilains
scientifiques qui répandent des
mensonges pour vous cacher la vérité
dans les milieux scientifiques officiels
vous savez les gens qui savent pas de
quoi ils parlent parce que c'est pas
leur métier de savoir ces choses-là
devait le Star Wars serait une lacolyte
Rogue remarquée encore une fois
l'usage d'un terme jargonneux que
personne ne connaît résultant d'un
jaillissement de magma en provenance des
profondeurs de l'écorce terrestre et
remarquer l'usage de trois petits points
pour ridiculiser l'hypothèse à la fin
évidemment c'est genre genre point de
suspension c'est littéralement ce que ça
veut dire je suspends je suspends je
laisse suspendu cette explication en
disant oh dans le milieu scientifique
officiel Devil Star Wars c'est une
lacolyte résultant de magma en
provenance des profondeur de l'école
stérées
cailloux n'est-ce pas
je me je me gosse de cette explication
pour les chercheurs de vérité alors là
ça change tout cette explication est
difficilement acceptable bobo bon bah
oui on n'a jamais vu de on n'a jamais vu
de la colite on n'a jamais vu de
d'orgues baseltique vous voyez il a
l'emploi de l'acolyte au lieu d'orgue
basaltique encore une fois
le jargon exprès le tartiner du jargon
pour susciter l'incrédulité pour la
simple raison alors là je suis curieux
c'est difficilement acceptable pour les
chercheurs de vérité là je suis curieux
j'ai pas lu l'article je suis curieux de
ce qui va sortir là
pour la simple raison que les formations
de coulées de lave ne présentent jamais
l'apparence
géophysique entre guillemets
employer un mot savant mais je suis pas
sûr de ce que ça veut dire alors j'ai
mis des guillemets jamais l'apparence
géo physique que l'on observe avec la
tour du diable
on observe jamais les coulées de lave ne
présentent jamais l'apparence que l'on
observe avec la tour du diable
je me permets de vous remettre le Piton
de la Fournaise et ses orgues
basaltiques
aucun doute quand un interprétation de
ce qui de ce qui se trompe par ici bien
sûr c'est même pas des photos de
géologues ça c'est c'est juste des
photos de vacances
donc c'est les vacanciers qui vont Piton
de la Fournaise et qui observent les
orgues basaltiques voilà bon elles sont
là c'est la même chose c'est les mêmes
colonnes
que vous voyez ici et qu'on voit aussi à
la
[Musique]
à des villes stauer les orgues
basaltiques on a évidemment d'autres
formations comme la la Chaussée des
Géants
la fameuse Chaussée des Géants en
Irlande la Chaussée des Géants en
Irlande c'est aussi de l'orgue
basaltique alors elles sont vachement
plus jolies que celle du Piton de la
Fournaise tout ça c'est de la roche
volcanique et on le sait parce que je
veux dire cette roche elle a une
composition chimique qu'on sait analyser
donc pour les chercheurs de vérité on a
choisi de fermer les yeux sur le fait
qu'on a trouvé s'écouler de lave à côté
d'un volcan c'est ça qu'il est en train
de nous dire c'est on a trouvé s'écouler
de lave à côté d'un volcan et on a
choisi d'ignorer complètement ce que
c'était il est vrai que la tour nous
fait penser à une souche d'arbre géant
oui ça s'appelle une pareille de lit
merci au revoir
dans le livre des secretstrailles 1966
Robert Charroux nous parle de très
anciens de très anciennes cité vitrifiés
peut-il s'agir d'anciens vestiges
édifiés par des géants dans l’antiquité
et qui ont forgé nos mides actuelles
alors je sais pas mais ça ce que ce que
tu nous montre là ça s'appelle du grès
ça là ça c'est du grès sculpté par
l'érosion ça ressemble même pas
vaguement à des ruines antiques mais
genre même pas vaguement il est vrai que
la tour nous fait penser à la souche
d'un arbre géant que l'on aurait coupé
soigneusement à l'aide d'une
tronçonneuse ouais soigneusement
soigneusement faut le dire vite
faut le dire vite quand même
le mec le mec qui a tronçonné ça il
était un peu bourré très honnêtement et
si et si c'était et écoute-moi et si
c'était l'érosion encore une fois
l'érosion après tout ça bouffe la roche
et si c'était l'érosion
il va sans dire que le bûcheron devait
être gigantesque
ben oui évidemment s'il y a un gros
arbre qui a été coupé c'est évidemment
par un gros monsieur
mais oui
monsieur comme ça
[Musique]
[Rires]
ça a été dit voilà le mot est lâché si
un gros si c'est un gros da si les
géologues ont tous tort
[Rires]
il les chercheurs de vérita oraison si
il s'agit bien d'un grand arbre et s'il
a bien été coupé avec une tronçonneuse
alors le mec qui tenait la tronçonneuse
ça devait être un gros monsieur
si si si oui oui
évidemment
si la terre est une balle de golf alors
il y a des géants qui jouent au golf oui
oui c'est vrai
c'est vrai c'est vrai
si l'univers est un pancake alors il y a
un alors ce pancake qui a été cuisiné
par une cuisine hier géante oui c'est
vrai aussi
mais bon
avec des si vous savez
ce qui surprend c'est la connerie de
cette pardon ce qui surprend ce sont ces
sillons verticaux aux angles réguliers à
aux angles réguliers
parce qu'évidemment dans la tête des
chercheurs de vertus les formes
régulières ça n'existe pas dans la
nature c'est impossible c'est impossible
dois-je vous rappeler l'existence de
cette magnifique de ce magnifique brin
d'herbe que non j'avais parlé la
dernière fois qui est fait un cercle
complètement régulier vous savez c'est
un brin d'herbe crevé qui est ballotté
par le vent et qui du coup fait comme un
compas et dessine un cercle complètement
complètement parfait du coup là je vois
dois-je vous rappeler l'existence de la
pyrite ce cristal parfaitement cubique
dans sa forme naturelle donc mais oui
mais dans la tête des chercheurs de
vérita ce genre de forme géométrique
n'existe absolument pas ça forcément été
conçu
édifié est-elle des colonnes géantes
elle semble s'étirer en formation avec
une géométrie organisée ou brusquement
elle s'interromps par un sommet plat en
flat top comment expliquer que l'on
puisse trouver à la surface de l'immense
plateau de telle forme géométrique la
réponse est habituellement la réponse
habituelle que la science nous sert est
la suivante la nature utilise la façon
universelle des formes pour construire
ses chefs
de mon point de vue c'est peut-être
juste de l'enfumage va te faire
va te faire il vient de traiter
les géologues de menteurs va te faire
voilà tu le mérites tu le mérites
la nature utilise de façon universelle
ces formes pour construire ses chefs
vous connaissez la technique dite de
l'homme de paille vous savez quand vous
attribuez à quelqu'un d'autre un
argument de chiottes pour ensuite le
contrecarrer plus facilement bah là
c'est même plus un homme de paille à ce
niveau-là c'est il a même pas construit
le bonhomme en paille c'est aucun
scientifique n'a jamais répondu ça la
nature utilise de façon universelle ses
formes non non parce que ce que les
scientifiques disent ce qui est dit dans
the conversation c'est ce que je vous ai
lu tout à l'heure c'est la contraction
l'explication la plus courante de la
formation des orgues asiatiques et celle
de la contraction thermique
c'est la contraction thermique ça
refroidit ça se contracte et ça casse en
fait la durant la formation ça perd en
volume et du coup ça casse au niveau des
zones de faiblesse et il se trouve que
les zones de faiblesse parce que le
basalte a une structure cristalline pas
très très fortement cristalline puisque
c'est du basalte quand même mais c'est
quand même formé de cristaux ça forme
plus une patte de verre mais bref
passons sur les détails mais bref le
basalte a une structure cristalline qui
fait que quand ça se contracte en fait
ça va avoir des zones de cassure très
particulière qui sont justement de forme
géométrique ce qu'on voit très bien à la
Chaussée des Géants ceci dit encore une
fois ce n'est pas le cas de toutes les
orgues basaltiques vous avez vu sur
celle du Piton de la Fournaise c'est
beaucoup moins évident
les orgues basaltiques des fois ça peut
être juste des patatoïdes très
irréguliers vous voyez d'ailleurs ici
les irrégularités faut quand même avoir
les yeux de la foi pour voir des formes
ultra régulières ici ça c'est des formes
et ça va dans tous les sens regardez la
regarder ici là à la base en haut ok
c'est relativement régulier mais alors à
la base c'est un beau bordel
donc faut arrêter de faire de fantasmer
sur des formes régulières quand elles le
sont pas en fait on voit sur cette photo
de la devilstower prise à sa base qu'il
est difficile de croire que sa formation
originelle vient du jaillissement d'une
lave en provenance du manteau terrestre
ouais tu es un menteur très cher puisque
la base ça ressemble à ça
ça ressemble pas à ça ça c'est pas la
base ça c'est le sommet ça c'est là où
c'est là où justement le refroidissement
était un peu différent c'est il faut
aussi une température
température particulière pour former des
orgues basaltiques évidemment que ça se
forme pas dans toutes les conditions
donc non c'est tout à fait tout à fait
le refroidissement et tout à fait un
mensonge de dire que ça ressemble à ça à
la base en plus
le fait jamais aucun géologue ou
volcanologue je redoute ce qui va
comment va finir cette phrase jamais
aucun géologue ou volcanologue et
qu'est-ce qui va dire après de fait
jamais aucun géologue volcaologue n'a
observé un tel phénomène aussi
remarquable
sauf dans les volcans modernes
sauf au Piton de la Fournaise
c'est le principe d'actualisme mec on
sort pas les choses de nulle part les
géologues de manière générale ne sortent
pas les choses de nulle part c'est on
n'a pas regardé les géologues n'ont pas
regardé la divine Star Wars en se disant
bah oui c'est du basalte évidemment que
c'est du bazars alors les géologues ils
ont regardé la devilstower ils ont dit
ça ça ressemble vachement beaucoup
franchement un truc que j'ai vu se
former sur un volcan allons voir ils
sont allés voir ils ont fait une ils ont
pris des échantillons on fait des
sections polies les ont regardé au
microscope donc ils ont on a des
microscopes qui font aussi lumière
polarisées parce que ça aide à
identifier les cristaux et en voyant la
structure cristalline au microscope on
en déduit que c'est du basalte parce
qu'on constate que il y a exactement les
mêmes cristaux que ce qu'on retrouve
dans les roches qui sont à côté des
volcans vous savez celle où il y a déjà
des orgues basaltiques
c'est comme ça que ça a marché à la
débile Star Wars et pas autrement c'est
pas on a vu on a dit mais non mais ta
gueule c'est des angles basiques ça se
voit bien ben non c'est pas comme ça que
ça s'est passé on a fait une hypothèse
basée sur des observations sur le
principe d'actualisme
expérimentation on a fait un prix un
échantillon fait des sections s'il
s'agit bien de basalte on va y retrouver
exactement les mêmes minéraux la même
structure minérale pétrologique
pétrographique pardon que sur les
basaltes prélevées sur un volcan dont on
est sûr qu'ils sont d'origine volcanique
et pas c'est la même chose de fait
jamais aucun géologue ou volcanologue
n'a observé un tel phénomène aussi
remarquable c'était effectivement un
énorme un gigantesque
un cracra mensonge c'est un énorme
mensonge on vous ment des gens ont payé
7 euros pour qu'on leur manque
7 euros pour qu'on vous mentent mesdames
et messieurs c'est vraiment le chasseur
qui s'adresse aux pigeon vous avez là il
est parti à la chasse au pigeon voilà il
est avec son fusil dans son petit cache
dans son petit cache et il attire les
pigeons
alors
de plus
je me suis interrogé sur ce point
et j'ai trouvé le plus éminent chercheur
en la matière le professeur Nick Hunter
géologue de renom à la centrale
Washington University aux États-Unis sur
elamsburg remarquez quand même qu'on
précise bien géologue de renom parce que
pour le sachant qu'on s'apprête à le
ridiculiser on va bien préciser avant
toute chose que le mec qui pèse dans le
game sinon c'est pas drôle sinon c'est
pas drôle donc voici notre échange le
magma n'a pourtant pas pour habitude de
se maintenir sur cette hauteur en
formant de telles figures géométriques
on n'a jamais vu ça qui est on
Pascal je suis ravi de répondre à vos
questions oui il n'y a pas plus il n'y a
plus ce genre de coulée de lave actif
sur notre planète aujourd'hui formant ce
genre de concentration parce que ces
matières sont à 100 pieds et plus mais
ce fut courant il y a longtemps je
comprends même pas la réponse il est
quand même il est quand même il est
quand même bonne pâte le nixenter parce
qu'il commence par je suis ravi de
répondre à vos questions
oh moi moi ce serait clairement
vous vous me faites chier et je vais
être très clair avec vous et vous avez
tort
oui je fais pas dans la dentelle quand
on me prend pour un con parce que là
clairement le but c'est de prendre
monsieur le docteur Zenter ou le
professeur menzhenter pour un con
professeur trois petits points petits
points de suspension parce que je vais
vous prendre pour un con comment le
magma a-t-il réussi une telle
performance en terminant sa course par
un sommet parfaitement plat et c'est
l'érosion ça c'est
pas parfaitement plat mes couilles je
veux dire parfaitement plat mes couilles
déjà
d'une parfaitement plat mes couilles de
deux il y a une surface vous savez une
coulée de basalte il y a forcément une
surface et la surface elle est plate et
de 3 lesrosion l'érosion elle explique
plein de choses voilà attends je le
magma n'a pourtant pas pour habitude de
se maintenir sur cette hauteur en
formant de telles figure géométrique
voilà
j'essaye je vous jure j'essaye de
comprendre cet échange mais il est dur à
il a traduit ça à la zob le magma n'a
pourtant pas pour habitude de se
maintenir à cette hauteur bah si un
volcan c'est haut qu'est-ce que tu
racontes mec tu as jamais vu un volcan
haut
un volcan c'est une montagne et au but
en formant de telles figures
géométriques bah si on les voit au Piton
de la Fournaise donc si donc je sais pas
pourquoi il lui répond qu'il n'y a plus
ce genre de coulé de notre planète
aujourd'hui c'est pas vrai elles sont
enfouies à la limite parce qu'il faut
une certaine température de
refroidissement si vous refroidissez le
magma trop vite il va effectivement pas
former des des belles orgues basaltiques
il faut quand même que le mal qu'il y
ait une réserve de magma souterraine
pour qu'elle se refroidisse relativement
lentement pour que la structure
cristalline impose ces formes
géométriques donc c'est pas le magma qui
se refroidit en surface qui forme ça à
la limite c'est peut-être ça qu'il a
voulu dire et du coup on n'est pas
capable de les voir aujourd'hui
se former directement quand le magma
coule j'entends quand la lave s'écoule
sur les côtés du volcan parce que
effectivement quand elle s'écoule sur
les côtés du volcan le refroidissement
est trop rapide donc ça forme des coulé
quoi sa forme découler et si c'est dans
l'eau ça forme des coussins
mécanique façon tout le Japon est un
archipel volcanique donc
c'est volcanique voilà c'est là c'est
clairement dit c'est d'origine
volcanique parce qu'on le retrouve sur
des volcans modernes c'est quand même
pas compliqué c'est là c'est écrit là
donc effectivement au-dessus il confirme
que il faut quand même une certaine
épaisseur parce que ça permet justement
la cristallisation si c'est trop faim
vous allez voir des vous allez vraiment
avoir une pâte un verre donc là il
confirme bien ce que je vous disais
qu'il faut quand même que ça refroidisse
à une certaine température pour former
des orgues et donc là il confirme que
c'est d'origine volcanique parce qu'on
le retrouve sur des volcans modernes le
fameux principe d'actualisme
pourriez-vous imaginer je vous prie il y
a pas besoin d'imaginer que des villes
Star Wars et d'autres puissent être
autre chose une source d'arbre
fossilisée par exemple la réponse de
notre bon professeur nicksenter à ce
moment là c'est de lui dire si c'était
un arbre on devrait y voir des
structures biologiques à l'intérieur or
quand on fait des coupes dans des orgues
basaltiques tels que celles de Devils
Star Wars on y constate une structure
cristalline typique du basalte
on ne voit pas de petites cellules parce
que dans un arbre fossilisé quand on
fait des sections on voit les cellules
ça se voit la structure de l'arbre la
structure du bois se voit sur les
sections mais ça ça comme Nick Thunder
je pense n'est pas paléontologue mais
géologue il va pas partir là-dessus il
va partir sur il y a un mouvement sur le
web très récent l'iant ses colonnes de
basalte avec des souches d'arbres géants
alors je te rassure monsieur Nick x
Hunter ce mouvement il est pas récent
les créationnistes des années 50
sortaient déjà ça à l'époque mais pour
moi en tant que scientifique je n'ai
aucune base pour confirmer ces
affirmations il faut être prudent mon
étude sur ses colonnes montre qu'elle
exclut de telles affirmations donc ça
c'est ce qu'il dit mon étude sur cette
colonne montre qu'elle exclut de telles
affirmations
il n'a pas voulu il a pas voulu lui dire
non mais on a regardé au microscope
c'est du basalte connard il a pas voulu
lui dire parce que il est trop poli il
est trop poli ou alors encore une fois
comme c'est la retranscription de
Monsieur les géologues sont des menteurs
ben évidemment il va pas sortir le pavé
d'arguments qu'il a dû lui sortir à ce
moment-là
donc soit monsieur Hunter est trop poli
soit monsieur PV les géologues sont des
menteurs
à tronquer l'échange pour nous regarder
que la partie où il donne aucune
explication je suis sûr qu'il vous ment
là je suis sûr que ce cet échange a été
tronqué parce que l'autre en plus la
table l'autre il le prend d'eux c'est
horrible quoi professeur trois petits
points le mec qui se pointe il a que des
questions mec je te je suis là je suis
là je te prends pas pour un con tu vois
je suis ravi de répondre à vos questions
tu vois je je suis là en tant
qu'autorité que tu as sollicité pour
répondre à tes questions à la con était
encore là à me prendre de haut espèce
que dire alors de ses formes hexagonales
que l'on retrouve sur de nombreux sites
la lave aurait-elle une sorte de mémoire
de forme
c'est bonjour je viens orienter ta
réponse veux-tu bien confirmer les
conneries que je crois c'est une
question de refroidissement la forme
hexagonale des colonnes est un problème
de physique impliquant leur
rétrécissement et la contraction des
surfaces voilà c'est exactement ce que
ce que je vous disais tout à l'heure
est-ce que disait l'article dans the
conversation cette forme hexagonale
c'est juste un problème de physique
c'est comme ça en fait que la c'est si
vous voulez c'est une optimisation des
contraintes ceci dit je vous invite à
regarder la photo que lui-même vous
donne monsieur les géologues sont des
menteurs et de constater à quel point
ces formes exagonales sont d'une
perfection parfaite notamment celle-ci
waouh je suis impressionné par la
géométrie parfaite de cette dalle de
même que celle là qui est probablement
pas du tout hexagonale la vue la forme
alors ok si on focus sur celle là celle
là ces trois-là qui sont au centre de
l'image donc on vous invite à focuser
sur celle là évidemment elles ont l'air
complètement parfaitement hexagonale
mais enfin la patatoïde là qui se trouve
ici vous avez pas me dire qu'elle est
hexagonale et là non plus du coup ça
forme pas du tout un hexagone cette
histoire et puis alors celle-là elle est
quasiment ronde bah c'est ce que je vous
disais tout à l'heure il y a des
patatoides il y a des ronces ça forme
hexagonale oui c'est ce que ça va former
ça va tendre vers une forme hexagonale
spontanément parce que c'est la façon
dont se contrat de la roche du fait ça
structure cristalline
mais sinon c'est tout c'est tout c'est
ça va tendre vers une forme hexagonale
mais ça va jamais être un hexagone
parfait donc l'entretien se termine là
visiblement puisque là pouf c'est la
dernière c'est la fin là vous voyez les
guillemets se referment ici analyse et
donc à côté de ça Nick Thunder exclut
l'hypothèse de la coulée de la
basaltique d'un volcan
c'est exactement ce qu'il t'a dit il t'a
dit c'est une question de
refroidissement la forme hexagonale des
colonnes est un problème de physique
impliquant le rétrécissement et la
contraction des surfaces la contraction
contraction du Bassat la contraction des
laves là ils te la dit plus haut c'est
c'est et il a dit non c'est pas un arbre
géant il t'a dit non c'est pas un arbre
géant c'est du basalte pourquoi pourquoi
tu fais mentir nixenter pourquoi tu fais
mentir ningzhenter détails de la débile
stauer à gauche la base de la montagne
forme des lignes verticales qui
ressemblent étrangement à l'écorce d'un
arbre
ça fait longtemps que tu as pas vu
d'arbre
ça fait longtemps que
ça fait t'es pas allé en forêt depuis
combien de milliers de milliers d'années
ça fait combien de temps que tu as pas
vu les Corses d'un arbre quel arbre à
une Corse comme ça à droite les détails
en coupe des lignes montrent une
structure en nid d'abeilles la structure
en nid d'abeille qu'on retrouve dans
tous les arbres quand on coupe un arbre
on retrouve une structure en nid
d'abeille le saviez-vous mais oui tout
le monde sait ça voyons tout le monde
sait que quand on coupe un arbre ce sont
pas des cercles concentriques
que qui regardait au microscope ont des
petites cellules à l'intérieur qui n'ont
pas du tout des formes hexagonales
d'ailleurs mais qu'on retrouve des
petites cellules à l'intérieur non non
tout le monde sait que quand on coupe un
arbre ce sont des formes hexagonales en
nid d'abeilles évidemment évidemment
c'est un fait extrêmement connu de tous
les enfants qui sont au CP évidemment
le niveau de mensonge de ce mec
m'exaspère analyse vous l'aurez compris
le professeur nigenter rejette l'idée
que ses édifices puis être autre chose
que dès la colite
mais alors du coup nixenter exclut
l'hypothèse de la coulée de lave
basaltique d'un volcan et à côté il
écrit le professeur nigenter rejette
l'idée que ses études puissent que ces
édifices puissent être autre chose que
des lacs
ces deux phrases
son diamètre allemand opposées je
je
c'est à dire que on peut être à la fois
un menteur et incohérent c'est beau
inutile de vous dire que j'ai contacté
plusieurs de ces confrères qui restent
sur la même position oui parce que on a
l'épreuve oui c'est pour ça mais eux
n'avait semble-t-il jamais eu vent de la
théorie des sources d'arbres géantes oui
parce que eux contrairement à toi ont un
cercle d'amis sain d'esprit il faut se
mettre d'accord sur ce qu'on doit
retenir de notre entretien avec le
professeur Zenter oui c'est un expert et
il dit que tu as tort c'est tout ce
qu'il y a à retenir sur ton entretien
avec professeur Zenter
d'abord il nous affirme qu'il n'y a plus
de coulée de lave actifs de ce genre sur
la terre depuis X millions d'années
c'est le principal point à retenir c'est
c'est pas x millions d'années non s'il y
en a Hawaï et que s'il y en a sur le
piton de la Fournaise on est tout au
plus sur des milliers d'années et il n'a
pas dit et puis de la façon dont c'était
traduit pour être tout à fait honnête je
pense que ce qu'il voulait dire
réellement c'est qu'on peut pas observer
puisque ça se passe sous terre en ce
moment il confirme que personne n'a
jamais observé de telle coulées en
formation oui ben je il confirme aussi
que ça se passe sous terre donc encore
une fois à moins que tu es à moins que
tu es un moyen de nager sous terre
globalement non tu les verras pas se
former dans un même temps il explique
que ces éruptions basesiques étaient
très épaisses oui c'est pour ça que tu
peux pas les voir et c'est pour ça qu'il
faut attendre que l'érosion les expose
mais quand les érosion quand l'érosion
les expose ben on voit exactement ce
qu'on s'attend à voir c'est à dire des
orgues basaltiques
j'ai eu beau chercher toujours en
interrogeant les meilleurs géologues
aucun de ces scientifiques n'a été en
mesure de me dire où se trouvait ce
fameux magma plus épais ou plus dans ce
qu'avant magma qui se serait enfoui sous
en sous-sol bah moi tu m'aurais demandé
à moi je t'aurais dit le Piton de la
Fournaise
était le cas monte il fait remarquer
cela remettrait en question tout ce que
l'on croit savoir sur la nature du
manteau terrestre
je vois où il veut en venir et je sens
que ça va me plaire
tout ça pour la simple raison qu'il
n'existe qu'une seule forme de magma
depuis des millions des millions
d'années c'est celui produit par le
noyau liquide au centre de la Terre
je viens d'avoir une remontée de mes
cours de SVT de on est de où là
on est au moins en collège là une petite
remontée de mes cours de collège
tu te rappelles quand on t'a expliqué au
collège je vais peut-être même au CM2
qui a des volcans effusifs et des
volcans explosifs
et qu'on t'a expliqué que la raison pour
cela c'était que l'un avait de la lave
fluide et l'autre avait de la lave pas
fluide ben voilà il existe n supérieur à
un type de lave aujourd'hui je reprends
les bases il existe bien plus de type de
lave que ça et encore plus si on remonte
dans les millions et les millions
d'années dont il nous parle alors et
puis de dire c'est le produit du noyau
liquide au centre de la Terre
on en est là quoi on en est là
on est sur
on est sur quelqu'un là qui est encore
au niveau au niveau CP quoi je veux dire
c'est scientifiquement cette phrase est
du niveau CP c'est il y a que les gamins
il y a que les gamins en fait il y a que
les bébés de 6 ans qui disent ah bah non
il y a que les bébés qui pensent ça
maman je vais arrêter de lire le
monsieur il est méchant
le monsieur il est méchant sa graisse
c'est agressif là c'est corrosif je suis
en train de m'éroder les yeux en
regardant ça
le mec meuf
et j'ai commencé en me disant et on va
rigoler par Toutatice
j'ai commencé en disant on va rigoler et
là je te jure j'ai envie de dévisser des
têtes là
les termes qui différencieront la
matière du magma dans sa nomination
c'est l'aspect final qu'il prendra une
fois refroidi au contact de l'atmosphère
de l'eau ou du sol de fait nos
scientifiques affirment que la
température du noyau solide n'a pas
varié depuis qui est apparu la croûte
terrestre ainsi dans le manteau
terrestre le magma s'élève vers la
surface par l'effet de cellules de
convection par échange de chaleur c'est
une mécanique des couches qui ne
survient que dans des milieux fluides
sans besoin d'entrer dans les détails de
bollywoodkins en 1839 déjà expliqué que
ces Flynn magmatiques existaient en 7
états depuis le début de l'histoire de
la Terre
j'ai lu Wikipédia j'ai copié collé j'ai
pas cherché à comprendre ce que
j'écrivais c'est toujours ainsi que le
magma a été défini et représenté bien
que parfois les esprits divergent et
divergent ça fait beaucoup en
particulier sur
l'asthénosphère last
j'utilise pas des mots que tu comprends
pas
des mots que tu comprends pas faut
arrêter loin de moi l'idée de mettre en
doute les compétences des géologues ah
bon
tu veux dire les géologues que tu as
accusé d'enfumage une page plutôt tu ne
remets pas tu remets pas en doute leurs
compétences les géologues que tu prends
pour des cons pendant ton interview là
cela là tu remets pas leur compétences
en question
genre la phrase qui commence par loin de
moi l'idée de remettre en doute les
compétences des géologues mais
je suis pas raciste mais
quand même un bon les gens qui ont une
couleur de peau bon je suis pas je suis
pas climatoceptique mais quand même si
la terre se réchauffait on n'aurait pas
si froid en hiver
je suis pas complotiste mais quand même
comme par hasard
c'est un bruit d'Anne que j'aurais dû
faire là
cependant se poser des questions sur
leurs affirmations touchant à la Devil
Star Wars et d'autres sites similaires
ces affirmations ne sont pas fiables en
effet rien ne vient les confirmer il
faut savoir que les géologues n'ont pas
étudié les structures internes de ces
lignes de sol de les structures internes
de ces lignes en sous-sol ils ne
disposent que de probabilités très
schématiques sur les interactions de
l'écorce et du manteau terrestre B6 B6
on les a étudiés puisqu'elles sont
visibles à la surface elles sont là mais
si quand les étudie c'est pas parce
qu'on les a vu se former de toute façon
les mêmes là j'ai presque failli tomber
dans le panneau mais en réalité c'est de
la merde ce qui est raconté là pour la
simple et bonne raison qu'encore une
fois on voit ces orgues basaltiques à la
surface on peut en étudier la
pétrographie cette pétrographie cette
structure chimique est la même que celle
du basalte
quand il ne forment pas des orgues
basaltiques
vous process c'est la même composition
chimique juste cristallisée différemment
regardez-moi ça en plus ouais je vois là
mais sur la photo ils vous montrent ça
et il vous montre ça genre vous avez
bien vu ça c'est pas la même chose que
ça alors forcément des raisons c'est
raisons la vie la vie est facile la vie
est simple on n'a pas besoin de
spécialiste
je m'interroge bah tu devrais pas
ou alors tu devrais te poser les bonnes
questions parce que se poser la question
est-ce qu'on sait vraiment que ces
lignes se forment en sous-sol la nanana
bah oui quand elle s’érode on voit bien
que ce ça s'est formé en sous-sol
puisque avant que ça sert on le voyait
pas
c'est tout bête une fois qui a érosion
on voit apparaître ces structures qu'on
ne voyait pas avant qui érosion donc
c'est structure se sont formés en
sous-sol c'est pas de la science-fiction
comme conclusion et il s'agit de basalte
puisqu'on leur rencontre dans des
endroits où le sol est exclusivement
composé de basalte le Piton de la
Fournaise Hawaii les archipels
volcaniques japonaises dont nous a parlé
Nick Hunter un peu plus haut
un peu plus haut
c'est c'est pas c'est pas je pense pas
faire des raccourcis logiques de fou en
vous disant ça c'est quand bien même on
aurait aucune idée de comment se forme
les orgues basaltiques ce qui est faux
il suffit de se servir il suffit de
prendre un caillou et de polir la
surface de comparer à un truc dont on
est sûr que c'est du basalte et pouf
c'est pouf c'est gagné c'est fini il y a
pas besoin de les voir se former ça
c'est un c'est un truc chez les
chercheurs de vérité oui mais vous avez
jamais vu ce faire vous avez jamais vu
les pyramides d'être construites bah non
j'ai jamais vu pas plus que toi donc tu
es pas mieux disposé à dire comment ça
s'est produit en fait
c'est ni les géologues ni les chercheurs
de veritudes n'ont vu les orgues
basaltiques se formaient live mais par
contre les géologues eux ils apportent
la preuve que ce que c'est du basalte et
rien d'autre
alors que les chercheurs de vertueux ils
rapportent quoi des questions des
questions très connes mais que des
questions tout ce qu'il a mis sur la
table jusqu'à présent c'est oh je
m'interroge hein et là il continue à
mettre ça sur la table je m'interroge je
m'interroge je m'interroge bah oui mais
arrête de te poser des questions accepte
les réponses ouverture d'esprit
vous voyez je vous disais tout à l'heure
la l'ouverture d'esprit la meilleure
excuse pour la fermeture d'esprit qui
les chercheurs de vérita n'ont jamais
inventé l'ouverture d'esprit
l'ouverture d'esprit c'est accepter les
réponses qu'on te donne quand elles sont
vérifiables et vérifiées et là ça
s'arrêtait pété et répété ces
observations il suffit juste de savoir
où chercher et là en l'occurrence il a
demandé à des géologues je suis sûr
qu'il lui ont fourni des quantités mais
monstrueuses d'articles des quantités je
veux dire je suis sûr je suis même sûr
et certain qu'il y en a un qui leur a
dit eh viens voir dans mon labo je vais
te montrer
je suis certain parce que les orgues
basaltiques c'est pas rare il y en a
partout et ça forme pas des troncs
d'arbres ça forme pas les troncs
d'arbres c'est une couche en fait ça se
voit c'est une couche qui s'étend sur
plusieurs kilomètres ça forme pas un
tronc comme un Devil stauer ça ça c'est
une coïncidence que ça forme vaguement
un tronc ou ses peut-être dû au fait que
c'était dans la cheminée volcanique que
ça se passait mais
les orgues basaltiques ça forme des
couches généralement et sa forme de très
longues couches ça ressemble pas du tout
à des arbres je m'interroge nous dit-il
il semblerait que la science officielle
s'est arrangée pour trouver le moyen de
cacher ses souches d'arbres au public
[Rires]
faut en avoir et là franchement
faut en avoir des boloss en acier trempé
là de la testiculasse de la Renesse pour
poser cette phrase là en te parlant de
devilstower qui n'a fait ni plus ni
moins qu'une apparition dans l'un des
plus grands films de science-fiction
il faut en avoir une paire de couilles
en acier trempé pour la poser sur la
table devant les scientifiques là leur
chatouiller le nez avec et dire eh dis
donc tu l'as caché à tout le monde
celle-là
non mais évidemment on a caché
l'existence de la Devil tower
on a nature sa nature de tronc d'arbre a
toujours été accepté par la totalité du
monde évidemment
[Rires]
on en est loin de la fin là s'il vous
plaît je deviens fou je devenais un fou
[Musique]
il serait entendre se poser la question
y a-t-il quelque part des traces de
branchages fossile pétrifiés
le biais de confirmation mesdames et
messieurs
tout le monde m'a dit que j'avais j'ai
interrogé tous les spécialistes de du
monde tout le monde m'a dit ta gueule tu
racontes de la merde arrête vraiment
sérieuse c'est pas bon pour ta santé
faut que tu arrêtes j'ai constaté tous
les experts du monde tout le monde m'a
dit faut que j'arrête c'est des
conneries faut pas continuer dans cette
voie là ça ne sert à rien tu tu vas te
perdre tout le monde m'a dit et moi j'ai
dit non je vais trouver les branches je
vous dis que c'est un tronc d'arbre et
je vous dis que je vais trouver les
branches tiens
c'est le gars il est en sens contraire
sur l'autoroute il y a 10 000 panneaux
sens interdit le gars il dit non non
c'est pas moi qui ai tort c'est les
panneaux
[Rires]
je veux devenir fou
je devenais fou
je pensais pas je pensais pas en
commençant un truc des bonnes câbles en
15 minutes même pas au début de la vidéo
j'ai dû débonquer ça en deux minutes
même pas je
pensais pas que ça irait aussi loin
il serait temps de se poser la question
y a-t-il quelque part des traces de
branchages fossiles pétrifiés mais du
coup tu acceptes tu acceptes-tu
l'existence des fossiles parce que les
fossiles c'est étudié par des
paléontologues officiels donc je sais
pas du coup quelle est la quantité de
science que tu acceptes dans ta
conception du monde et quelle est la
continuité de science que tu refuses
tant que en fait tant que ça dit qu'il y
a des arbres géantes acceptent et sinon
non en fait c'est ça l'idée je le
comprends pas
voici qui vient conforter notre
hypothèse les végétaux se pétrifient
effectivement sous forme de roches oui
jamais personne t'auras dit le contraire
ceci étant dit si vous êtes déjà allé
dans les terrils du Nord vous le savez
il existe de nombreux musées à ciel
ouvert à travers le monde souvent
occultés par les médias scientifiques
j'attends qu'il me donne des exemples de
musées enfin des musées à ciel ouvert
occulté par les médias et scientifiques
genre à quel point parce que là si ils
nous montrent ça enfin je veux dire
c'est monument de valaise
c'est dans tous les films de dans tous
les western vous le voyez ces trucs là
si ça c'est des fils ça c'est des trucs
qui ont été cachés par les scientifiques
mais normalement même si vous même vous
croyez à cette théorie à ce moment-là
vous êtes en train de vous dire non mais
attends il se fout de ma gueule ça c'est
monument de vallée ça c'est c'est des
trucs qu'on voit dans tous les westerns
de tous les films de John Wayne ça y est
donc des exemples de souches aux
États-Unis ces configurations se
présentent
par centaines partout sur la planète oui
et si tu constates par toi même au moins
celle là elles ne sont pas faites de la
même structure que ce que tu nous a
présenté ici
celle-là elles ont aucune structure
hexagonale ça c'est ça c'est du grès
donc c'est du sable pétrifié ce n'est
pas des orgues basiques donc en plus on
est tellement dans un billet de
confirmation de la folie du cul que le
gars en vient à qualifier deux
structures totalement différentes comme
étant exactement la même chose sur la
base que vu de loin ça se ressemble bon
alors ces fameuses structures que les
scientifiques nous cachent comme la
forêt pétrifiée située à la limite des
provinces loro et de Laura dans le sud
de l'équateur
je me demande les forêts pétrifiés les
forêts pétrifiés sont un grand secret
dont on cache l'existence regardez
comment les scientifiques il nous
cachent l'existence des forêts
pétrifiées en en faisant des parcs
nationaux ah les
Forest National Park
et je vous dis pas combien il y en a des
pétroe fight forest le dire forêt même
je suis sûr en France il y en a des
forêts pétrifiées forêts pétrifié il y
en a parce qu'elle date du Carbonifère
les forêt pétrifiées Parc National
pétrify Forest il y en a Damart land
donc damartland c'est en Afrique du Sud
la forêt pétrifiées où est-ce qu'on en a
d'autres
Arizona ça va être la même en Bulgarie
il y en a une
Patagonie faut répéter de sarment en
Patagonie alors faut répéter France quoi
allez donne-moi une forêt pétrifiée là
dans les commentaires si vous connaissez
des forêt pétrifiées de chant Closon bah
voilà tiens j'étais allé la voir
la forêt pétrifiée de champloson donc
vous voyez des magnifiques troncs
d'arbres silifiés c'est un phénomène
tout à fait naturel que nous connaissons
voili voilà et jean-clauzon ça se situe
où parc national donc vous avez un
dinopedia pack de loisirs
visite de la forêt fossile et donc c'est
en Ardèche voilà Parc Naturel Régional
des Monts d'Ardèche
Wally Walla non non les forêt pétrifiées
c'est un grand secret c'est juste des
attractions touristiques ça doit brasser
la totalité des forêt pétrifiées du
monde doit brasser littéralement des
millions voire des milliards de
touristes mais oui c'est un grand secret
gardé par les plus parler plus fameux
scientifiques
[Rires]
faut vraiment être faut vraiment être
d'une mauvaise foi incroyable pour
oser balancer
il y a encore la forêt pétrifiée de
dammarland en Afrique du Sud bah tiens
voilà tu vois
on l'a vu elle est sur Internet c'est
visité c'est trouvable c'est là le
dammarland on l'a vu là tout à l'heure
on a on a juste tapé forêt pétrifier sur
Internet et on est tombé dessus
immédiatement la secrète des
scientifiques ça a pas été écrit en 1970
ça a été écrit en 2017
7 euros 7 euros pour vous faire tartiner
la tronche de bullshit comme ça je veux
dire le mec il est même pas capable
d'aller Google et pétri fight forest
pour constater de ses propres yeux enfin
c'est même pas ça je suis sûr qu'il l'a
google et je suis sûr qu'il est même pas
au courant à la base qui a une forêt
pétrifiée en Afrique du Sud c'est juste
qu'il l'a Google et il l'a trouvé et
après il écrit dans son truc il veut
vous faire croire que c'est pas connu
que c'est un secret gardé par les
scientifiques j'étais même pas au
courant
je suis parlé anthologue en Afrique du
Sud j'étais même pas au courant donc
comment voulez-vous que je le garde le
secret je suis même pas au courant du
secret merde on me dit jamais rien à moi
zen par pitié dites-moi que c'est la
dernière page oh on a encore
trois pages
bon je vais accélérer
le mec vous ment voilà c'est
en conclusion le mec vous ment le mec
vous met des photos de des photos de
souches des photos de montagne une photo
de souche une photo de montagne une
photo de souche une photo de montagne oh
bah dis donc ça ressemble les montagnes
elle ressemble à des troncs d'arbres
des photos de source des photos de
montagne ah le niveau de preuve est
même pas m'emmerder en Italie et au
Venezuela parmi des centaines d'autres
lieux on trouve des tas de configuration
de souches fossiles semblant avoir été
comme arraché ah bah faut savoir ça a
été coupé ou ça a été arraché oh
enfin pour ne citer que les plus connus
ah bon bah
à travers le monde
occulté de occulté par les médias et les
scientifiques et là il nous parle les
plus connus bébé comment tu peux comment
tu peux écrire deux phrases d'affilée et
te contredire
à ce point
c'est le tissu de mensonge et de
contradiction c'est incroyable en fait à
ce niveau là 7 euros
7 euros pour acheter un truc
ou les articles vous racontent des
énormes conneries à tel point qu'ils ont
même pas vérifié qu'ils avaient écrit
des choses cohérentes les unes à la
suite des autres il est capable de vous
dire dans deux phrases consécutives
la vérité nous est cachée regardez ces
exemples bien connus
ces exemples bien connus de vérité
cachées mais de quoi tu nous parles de
quoi qu'est-ce que tu racontes tu es fou
tu es fou
pour ne citer que les plus connus aux
États-Unis en Arizona nous avons une
forêt pétrifiée ces tendances sur 608
km². appeler petreyfight Forest National
Park c'est juste un parc naturel
tellement occulté par les scientifiques
vous voyez on croit à tort que cette
forêt présente un cas unique
oui tu viens de nous en présenter trois
mais on croit qui sait ont quels sont
les
qui sont les neuneus qui croient c'est
on c'est qui ce on
croit à tort que cette que cette forêt
présente un cas unique certains
chercheurs de vérité
voit ici non pas des troncs fossilisés
comme le prétend la version officielle
mais des branches d'arbres géants qui
semblent avoir été coupés à l'origine et
empilés puis disperser au cours du temps
alors la raison pour laquelle on pense
que ce sont des arbres géants et non pas
des enfin et non pas des juste des
branches géantes parce qu'ils ont des
racines donc on a les arbres qui sont
préservés vous voyez à la verticale
avec leur système racinaire en place bon
bah voilà donc c'est bien la preuve que
c'est pas une branche mais bel et bien
un arbre
voilà voilà c'est parce qu'ils sont
présents si c'était si c'était des
branches il serait forcément tomber je
veux dire
c'est là on parle bien de branches qui
sont tombées qui peut pas qui sont
restés en place donc là si c'est
préservé à la verticale avec le système
racinaire
c'est qu'on est forcément
c'est qu'on est forcément sur un sur un
arbre pas sur une branche donc les
chercheurs de vérita voici non pas des
troncs d'arbres fossilisés comme le
prétend la version officielle mais des
branches d'arbres géantes qui semblent
avoir été coupées à l'origine et empiler
puis disperser au cours du temps donc ce
qui contredit ce qui contredit
complètement le fait qu'on les retrouve
en place il y a même aux États-Unis il y
a un parc naturel vous avez 27 niveaux
de Racine empiler les uns sur les autres
alors c'est vous dire si ce qui est
d'ailleurs aussi une preuve contre
l'existence du déluge comment ne pas
s'interroger
[Musique]
comment ne pas s'interroger c'est simple
il faut faire comme toi mettre des
grosses œillères et puis foncer tout
droit je vois pas sur les côtés je vais
tout droit je vois pas sur les côtés je
vais tout droit la science nous explique
que le processus de fossilisation se
produit sous terre lorsque le corps est
enterré sous les monceaux de sédiments
c'est ainsi que les corps se
préserveraient à l'abri de l'oxygène
ainsi pour qu'une pétrifie une
pétrification de cette ampleur se
réalise il aurait fallu une pression
colossale de sédiments
en vertu de
je vois pas la logique en fait
faut que ça se passe sous terre à aucun
moment il n'est question de pression
donc ça c'est juste je me prends pour un
scientifique et je vous donne une
explication bullshit qui n'est même pas
cohérente avec elle-même à aucun moment
il est question de pression de sédiments
qui faciliterait la fossilisation dans
son explication on trouve au sol dans la
forêt pétrifiée des bûches fossilisées
cristallisées en pierre semi-précieuse
de toutes les couleurs et c'est
merveilleux c'est plein de couleurs or
nous savons aujourd'hui que c'est
variations ne peuvent se produire que
sous l'effet d'une chaleur intense
et quand bien même ce serait le cas
qu'est-ce que ça prouve
c'est du moins ce que nous dit la
physique et pour témoigne nous avons nos
joyeux et diamantaires qui considèrent
le traitement thermique des pierres
précieuses comme une méthode de mise en
valeur naturelle ça n'a rien à voir
rien à voir en portant la température
des pierres à 1600 degrés il parviennent
en effet à modifier les couleurs des
pierres tout en affirme en affirmant
qu'il s'agit là du prolongement d'un
processus qui se produit sous terre oui
bon en augmentant la chaleur tu influ
avec la structure la structure physique
du truc et alors
ce phénomène est incontestable
on sait en effet qu'au moment de la
chose d'un matériau se produit une
modification de couleur mais je
comprends pas en quoi le fait que ce
soit chaud prouve que tu as raison je
est-ce qu'il va nous l'expliquer à un
moment pourquoi le fait que ce soit
chaud prouve que c'est des géants
je comprends pas
parce que la science la science
officielle admet très bien que les
fossiles se forment sous terre sous des
conditions de pression et de température
élevée bon ça ça rend pas les fossiles
plus beaux on est bien d'accord
ça les déforme plus qu'autre chose
l'acidification du bois on est bien
d'accord que c'est un processus qui
prend longtemps qui se fait sous terre
sous des conditions de pression qui
permettent à la silice circulant grâce à
l'eau sous terre de transporter les
cristaux et de remplacer petit à petit
la structure du bois oui d'accord mais
et que de toute façon sous terre tu as
forcément un gradient de température à
partir du moment où tu es sous terre tu
as un gradient de température donc la
température augmente effectivement mais
en quoi ça te donne raison exactement
la couleur obtenue correspondra à une
température la stabilisation de la
couleur choisie appliquera alors des
techniques de refroidissement il est en
train de vous bullsiter la face avec son
jargon technique c'est plus ou moins
rapide on se demande ce qui a bien pu se
passer en Arizona ou le constate le
phénomène de colorisation on se demande
ce qui a bien pu se passer en Arizona ou
l'on constate ce phénomène de
colorisation donc vous voyez le mec il
ramène que des questions et en fait en
bombardant comme ça les gens de
questions ils croient qu'il a raison
mais non tu as juste des questions et tu
ignores les réponses qu'on donne donc ça
non c'est pas comme ça que ça marche la
logique le temps n'est en rien
responsable à l'affaire
dans le fait rien à la fin quand on est
con on est con non c'est bien qu'il cite
les grands classiques de la chanson
française il a fallu qu'il se produise
une catastrophe de grande ampleur non
non
tu viens de dire l'enfouissement et
c'est tout l'enfouissement la tectonique
des plaques les millions d'années fin il
y a pas besoin de catastrophe de grande
ampleur qu'est-ce que tu racontes
qu'est-ce que tu racontes il y a besoin
d'une catastrophe de grande ampleur à
toi pour expliquer pourquoi on se
retrouve avec des branches partout mais
à partir du moment où tu parles du
principe que ce sont des forêts qui ont
tous des âges différents en plus parce
qu'il y en a du Crétacé il y en a de Léo
saigne on a des elles ont toutes des
millions d'années d'écart elles sont pas
toutes elles se sont pas toutes formées
à la même époque il y a que dans ta tête
à toi que ça nécessite une catastrophe
de grande ampleur pour faire de la
chaleur je sais pas quoi
alors donc tout à l'heure on nous a
parlé d'une tronçonneuse géante d'un
monsieur non moins géant qui aurait
coupé les arbres je viens de voir le mot
explosion dans le paragraphe suivant
[Rires]
voilà je veux juste vous dire qu'on en
est là on en est arrivé là dans ce point
de logique interne de cet article que
depuis tout à l'heure on nous vend que
les arbres ont été coupés nettes par une
tronçonneuse géante c'est ce qui s'est
passé là c'est ce qui s'est passé là
c'est ce qui s'est passé là selon lui
selon lui donc depuis tout à l'heure on
nous parle d'arbres géants qui ont été
coupés par des non moins géantes
tronçonneuses tenues par des non moins
géantes mains de géants
et donc maintenant je vois le mot
explosion dans le paragraphe suivant
je tiens juste à vous faire remarquer
dès maintenant
qu'on se dirige vers un énorme problème
de cohérence interne du récit
je vous préviens voilà ce il a fallu
qu'il se produise une catastrophe de
grande ampleur comme une explosion
générant une chaleur infernale et
pourtant rien sur le site ne semble
l'indiquer c'est pour ça que rien tu
sais pourquoi rien sur le site ne semble
indiquer que la couleur de la silice qui
a remplacé les arbres parce que les
arbres se sont plus des arbres
maintenant ce sont des blocs de silice
qui ont conservé la structure des arbres
donc on voit toujours les cellules mais
ce sont plus des armes maintenant ce
sont des cailloux chimiquement tu sais
pourquoi une grande explosion ne
transforme pas les arbres en silice
multicolore parce que le bois ça brûle
le feu c'est beau mais ça brûle je vous
jure on en est à ce niveau là le
débuncage le débuncash du siècle
Mesdames et Messieurs le mec te dit que
quand on brûle du bois ça fait du bois
multicolore
oui madame c'est ce qu'il est en train
de nous dire là
quand on brûle du bois ça fait du bois
multicolore comme ça mais ça c'est du
bois siliciié
la seule raison pour laquelle ce minéral
quand vous le chauffez il change de
couleur c'est parce qu'il est déjà
silifié c'est du minéral si vous brûlez
du bois pendant une explosion j'espère
ne pas avoir à vous convaincre que le
bois va pas se transformer en ça il va
brûler j'espère quand même qu'on en est
pas à ce niveau là on est niveau gamin
de trois ans là on est au niveau de
bulle la
gamin de trois ans qui comprend pas que
quand on met du bois au feu ça le brûle
waouh
gay
j'aime pas la science
[Musique]
ces arbres ou branches fossilisés en
pierre semi-précieuse reste un mystère
mais que dans ta tête mais absolument
mais il y a que dans ta tête il y a que
dans ta tête que ça reste un mystère
parce que même les gens qui te lisent et
qui ont payé 7 euros pour avoir envie de
te croire à ce niveau là
ils ont compris que tu racontes que tu
improvisais au fur et à mesure j'en sais
rien mais ils ont compris que
l'argumentaire il tient pas 4 secondes
tu te contredis d'une phrase à l'autre
et maintenant tu essayes de nous
expliquer que les arbres géants quand
ils ont brûlés se sont transformés en
silice
[Rires]
quoi quoi
les versions officielles sont très
rarement remises en cause les hypothèses
avancées il y a fort longtemps finissent
par devenir des dogmes et par et par
s'imposer en tant que réalité physique
comme par exemple le principe Carnot où
il est fait venturi on vous balance des
noms comme ça et on vous expliquera pas
ce que c'est autant dire que le
chercheur de vérité a du pain sur la
planche alors on essaye là qu'est-ce
qu'on essaie de faire bah évidemment on
essaie de faire passer la science pour
un dogme on essaie de faire passer la
science pour un dogme alors que la seule
personne ici qui a choisi de croire un
truc sans le remettre en question une
seule seconde c'est bien l'auteur de ces
lignes et personne d'autre
on trouve ce sol des forêts pétrifiées
des bûches fossilisées cristallisées en
pierre semi-précieuses comment ne pas
s'interroger en sachant que la science
nous certifie que le processus de
folieilisation se situe sous terre c'est
l'érosion qui amène les trucs enfin
c'est l'érosion qui ramène les trucs à
la surface c'est simple pourtant c'est
pas compliqué à comprendre
l'érosion ça a phénomène tout bête tu
fais pipi tu fais pipi sur une mode de
terre et la mode de terre c'est rode
voilà
hypothèse scientifique expérimentation
conclusion
ah des gros cailloux tout ronds on va
encore nous dire que les gros caillot
tout rond c'est trop compliqué ça peut
pas exister
donc maintenant on va des graines
fossiles non pourquoi pourquoi les gros
cailloux tout rond c'est des graines
fossiles
pourquoi j'ai lu pourquoi j'ai lu mes
yeux mes yeux ça nous brûle
dans
le globe
c'est la logique for blagouton
Valley socostar quoi les célèbres boules
de pierres
c'est c'est je vous jure je viens
d'entrer dans un nouvel univers de
bullshit c'est à dire que je connaissais
les je connaissais les les pyramiddios
et l'arché la pseudo archéologie je
connaissais les créationsnistes mais là
là je viens d'entrer dans là je viens de
péter la quatrième dimension là on est
dans un autre niveau de n'importe quoi
c'est une autre dimension du grand
n'importe quoi ça
valait de dickwitz au Costa Rica les
célèbres boules de Pierre ainsi le monde
oubliait des géants réapparaissent sous
forme que l'on attendait pas
maintenant là je m'y attendais pas là
vraiment j'étais pas prêt
le hors-série numéro 8 de top secret
Pascal Cazotte c'est alors là on est
dans l'autocitation de bullshitos
magazine
[Rires]
dans le numéro 8 de bullshitos magazine
on nous avait déjà raconté du bullshit
ah c'est surprenant ça dis donc Pascal
Cazotte c'est largement penché sur
l'existence des géants l'ouvrage
argumenté est bien documenté nous montre
l'importance du mythe des géants dans
les anciennes traditions et le folklore
puis alors c'est vrai que inventer
l'existence d'un grand monsieur ça
demande quand même un niveau
d'imagination que que nos ancêtres
pouvaient pas avoir vous imaginez bien
que nos ancêtres ils ont jamais pu avoir
l'imagination qu'il fallait qu'il
fallait pour s'imaginer un monsieur mais
juste en plus grand ici à présent nous
sommes confrontés à des vestiges
surprenants réputés avoir été conçus
sans intervention humaine et comme nous
l'avons vu ces souches d'arbres géant
fossilisés et leur branchages pétrifié
qui n'ont pas tous le même âge et qui
n'ont pas tous le même type de
préservation puisque vous avez des
arbres silifié mais ceux de chant Closon
sont pas si illicifiés ce sont des
empreintes de tronc d'arbre en réalité
donc
et qui d'ailleurs pour la plupart ne
sont même pas couchés mais sont encore
en position de vie
puisque c'est quand même une des
conditions pour avoir une forêt
pétrifiée c'est d'avoir
c'est pour qualifier à forêt pétrifier
il faut quand même que ce soit encore
plus ou moins en place avec un système
racinaire fossilisé donc bref
qui défile la logique et la science
un défi la science se retrouve partout
sur Terre ce voyage à travers le monde
lointain et gigantesque DG géants ne me
semblait pourtant pas complet j'avais le
sentiment qui me manquait encore quelque
chose je sais pas des preuves pas trop
teubées par exemple j'avais ces grands
arbres titanesques ces branchages tout
cela sous forme fossile j'avais un récit
qui avait l'air
j'avais un récit qui avait l'air
cohérent dans une dimension parallèle
mais encore me fallait-il plus de
preuves
imaginez une seconde le diamètre d'une
souche d'arbre est approximativement
égal à 1/20 de d'un arbre entier ainsi à
en croire cette hypothèse devilstower
aux États-Unis devait atteindre près de
6 km de hauteur des proportions
tellement considérables comment prendre
tout cela au sérieux et tu as raison
comment prendre comment prendre
l'existence d'un arbre de 6 km de
hauteur au sérieux
[Rires]
pénitences bravo
il faudrait encore au moins un autre
indice non mais ça arrête avec les
indices il faut des preuves mais avec
des preuves arrête avec les indices non
mais c'est vrai c'est ce qui manque il
manque un indice non il faudrait au
moins ouais
c'est ça qui manque un indice un indice
et une tonne derrière peut-être aussi
mais ça on verra après je me suis alors
souvenu de l'adage qui dit qu'on
reconnaît un arbre assez fruits je me
suis dit alors que si ces arbres géants
avaient réellement existé alors nous
devrions peut-être retrouver trace de
leurs fruits si on trouvait de telles
traces un peu partout dans le monde la
thèse commencerait alors à prendre corps
et peut-être sérieusement être discuté
je me suis alors souvenu d'une émission
diffusée il y a une décennie et
consacrée au mystère des boules de
pierre du Costa Rica c'est j'aime bien
quand il cite ses sources et je me
rappelle documentaire que j'ai vu il y a
10 ans c'est ma source mesdames et
messieurs
[Rires]
et parler des boules de pierre du Costa
Rica c'est faire de piédras Blanca noyau
blanc ont été trouvés dans les forêts de
la vallée de dix cuise dans les années
1930 300 sphères parfaites de taille
différente ont été retrouvées là au plus
profond de la jungle la plus grosse
mesure est 2 mètres 15 de diamètre et
peser 16 tonnes c'est se faire rocheuses
reste une énigme il est possible il est
impossible de les dater impossible
serait pas forcément vrai on sait
qu'elles sont
on sait qu'elles sont pas qu'elles n'ont
pas des millions d'années les pierres de
les pierres de 10 classes
donc les fameuses la vallée de Dickies
pardon au Costa Rica alors les fameuses
les fameuses pierres de dix cuisses bon
de toute façon je sais même pas pourquoi
je m'emmerde voilà période entre 500 et
tout se passe comme si il suffisait de
taper pour trouver une réponse à la date
encore une fois il est impossible de les
dater sous-entendu on ne sait pas les
dater du tout mais non on sait les dates
il est impossible de dater les pierres
elles-mêmes ça oui mais on a quand même
de elles ont quand même été retrouvées
dans un contexte archéologique qui
permet de donner une fourchette
et donc c'est la période archéologique
donc ça se compte seulement en centaines
d'années
1500 ans maximum
on est très loin des millions d'années
qui a fallu pour transformer ses
branches c'est soi-disant de branches en
fossiles impossible aussi d'attribuer
leur réalisation à un peuple ou une
civilisation connue impossible
impossible
impossible culture la culture d'ikis oh
impossible impossible de les attribuer à
une culture et pourtant et pourtant on
l'a attribué à une culture
[Musique]
aucun homme ne pourrait les manipuler
bah si il suffit de les faire rouler
[Rires]
c'est quoi ces affirmations ce qui
frappe l'observateur c'est leur parfaite
régularité et leur taille exceptionnelle
aucun homme ne pourrait les manipuler
je rappelle que si c'est des graines il
y a pas plus de raison qu'une graine
soit parfaitement sphérique que pour une
pierre d'être par parfaitement sphérique
donc la logique qui dit que
la logique qui dit que ce sont des
graines résous pas plus la question de
la perfection des sphères que la logique
qui dit que ça a été fabriqué par l'être
humain
les chercheurs ne comprennent pas non
plus leur utilité
regardons les chercheurs du futur ça
s'intéressait au cas des cathédrales et
essayer de comprendre à quoi ça servait
déjà les athées à notre époque se
demandent à quoi servent les cathédrales
alors
enfin un détail étonnant on ne trouve
pas ce style de roche à moins de 1000 km
du site comment et pourquoi ces boules
mystérieuses ont-elles pu être
transportées jusque là et bien je ne
vous donnerai pas la réponse en Sibérie
des ouvriers ont récemment fait une
découverte incroyable dans une mine de
charbon de la région de krask
ils ont eu la surprise de déterrer 30
mètres sous terre une dizaine de sphères
ronde et lisses d'un peu plus d'un mètre
de diamètre on dit que c'est sphère
aurait la particularité de changer de
couleur lorsqu'il pleut ah parce qu'en
plus ils se sont emmerdés à les sortir
des journaux ont eu la bonne idée de
faire courir le bruit qu'il s'agissait
deux fossilisés de dinosaures et les
institutions locales les ont rebaptisées
perdent du Jurassique
c'est ça les
est-ce que les noyaux des fruits
d'arbres géants fausses est-ce des
noyaux de fossiles d'arbres géants
fossilisés ou des fruits fossiles
d'arbres fruitiers géants
[Rires]
je sais pas moi tout ce que je vois là
c'est une figure d'érosion vous voyez
une sphère vous là parce que là encore à
la rigueur je veux bien imaginer qu'il y
avait une sphère et encore on voit que
c'est plus un nodule en réalité c'est un
nodule c'est une figure sédimentaire
assez classique l'absence totale de
barre d'échelle et là pour vous induire
en erreur en vous faisant croire que ce
truc là est gigantesque alors peut-être
il ne l'est pas du tout il y a pas de
barre d'échelle vous n'avez aucune idée
de la taille de ce buisson
idem pour ça il y a pas de barre
d'échelle ça ça ressemble à une figure
sédimentaire tout à fait classique avec
les lignes de sédimentation là voilà ça
ça ressemble à un nodule et ce nodule a
été mis à la verticale parce qu'il est
certainement tombé de là-haut il a roulé
Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam il était pas du tout
sphérique parce que si vous regardez le
bout qui manque le bouquin manque est
ici est beaucoup plus petit que le bout
que vous voyez là donc il était aplati
en réalité et là vous voyez les lignes
de sédimentation donc bref ce truc n'est
absolument pas sphérique mais est
absolument d'origine sédimentaire
puisqu'on voit encore les lignes de
sédimentation dessus rien de cela n'a
avoir avec les graines fossiles dont il
veut nous faire croire l'existence et le
truc de Sibérie qui date du Jurassique
qui donc ne date pas du tout de la même
période que c'est se faire là ou que de
ces que de ces troncs aussi du Crétacé
ou que de ce chant Closon du Carbonifère
bref
on nage dans un flou on nage dans un
flou artistique merveilleux donc on nous
montrera pas ces fameuses perles du
Jurassique de Sibérie et on nage dans un
flou artistique merveilleux où il
n'existe que deux temporalités à savoir
aujourd'hui et avant donc tant que ça se
passe avant ça peut être 1000 ans 2000
ans 4 millions d'années 30 millions
d'années 300 millions d'années 3
milliards d'années on s'en fout c'est
avant voilà il n'existe que deux
temporalités et c'est évidemment ce que
tous les scientifiques sérieux vous
diront que que avant c'est une
temporalité tout à fait valide mais oui
bien sûr les boules géantes de roche
découverte sur les plages de
moheraki en Nouvelle-Zélande sont
l'attraction de milliers de touristes
chaque année la mer a creusé les terres
et a laissé apparaître des centaines de
boules parfaitement rondes certaines
sont à moitié sous terre d'autres cassés
ou fendus révélant un creux un creux
central il y a d'autres roches qui sont
connues pour avoir un vide central ce
sont les géodes
docteur nozman quand il explose des
Géode à chaque fois il ouvre la Géode il
y a un vide au milieu c'est pas ça a
rien de particulier d'avoir un vide au
milieu personne ne comprend leur origine
ni la façon dont elles ont été produites
alors aucun chercheur de véritable les
géologues il le savent selon moi les
alentours n'ont pas suffisamment été
explorées oui la Nouvelle-Zélande c'est
complètement terrain connard mon grand
évidemment il y a personne qui habite en
Nouvelle-Zélande
les boules ne sont pas seulement
présentes sur les plages mais aussi en
plus sur des plages que je veux dire il
doit y avoir des touristes à long tour
de bras arrêtez de faire croire qu'il y
a personne qui allait voir quoi mais
aussi très loin sur les terres il suffit
de consulter Google Maps pour le
constater et c'est pour ça que tout le
monde est au courant d'ailleurs mais
surprise les systèmes Google Maps nous
empêche une approle nous empêche
l'approche visuelle du sol une sorte de
sens
et
la logique de cet article elle est quand
même folle parce que dès qu'on a
un petit point d'accroche la moindre
petite aspérité qui permet d'introduire
la moindre forme de soupçon de théorie
du complot mais alors le mec il s'y
accroche mais comme la misère sur le
pauvre peuple c'est horrible c'est
horrible de lire des choses comme ça
c'est
mais surprise le système Google nous
empêche d'aller voir
d'aller voir ce qui se passe au sol
pourquoi la navigation au sol est
également restreinte sur Google dans
cette zone alors je tape motheraki
moheraki bouledog Beach donc la table
des la table des bouboules
la plage des boules pardon donc la plage
des bouboules les voilà la admirer
admirait donc la perfect sphéricité des
bouboules on est on est vraiment pour
c'est complètement parfaitement
sphérique donc la plage de Moret
moreirachi on peut tout à fait trouver
un tas d'informations sur internet c'est
pas du tout un secret
et donc la plage des boules d'Ores on va
aller voir sur google maps voir s'il y a
réellement une censure
pas un Google Maps se charge
composition la roche a été utilisée la
roche a été étudiée par minéralogie
optique par rayon X cristallographie au
rayon X par
electron microbes donc par son de
électronique et il s'agit de sédiments
fin donc de la de l'argile de la Marne
et de la calcite donc absolument rien à
voir avec des graines fossilisées
[Musique]
et donc voyons voir un petit peu ce que
nous dit Google
moïraki buzzer Beach
ah dis donc
c'est vrai qu'on les voit pas c'est vrai
qu'on les voit pas les boules d'Ores dis
donc on les voit pas du tout on nous
cache on nous cache des choses donc
voilà le grand secret mesdames et
messieurs on nous cache la vérité tout
ça tout ça d'ailleurs mais c'est elle le
niveau de des bunkers là ça va ça arrive
vraiment au ras des pâquerettes c'est à
dire qu'il fait tellement d'affirmations
à la noix que ça ça regarde des niveaux
ça requiert même pas de niveau de
connaissances c'est ah bon ça se voit
pas sur google tu vas sur Google et pouf
tu vois ce que je veux dire c'est ah bon
ça se voit pas sur google tu vas sur
Google Maps et pouf ça se voit et puis
tu tapes moi et raki Beach et tu vois
immédiatement les boulders et tu vois
immédiatement qui sont pas se faire
ce sont tout sauf des sphères parfaites
c'est fou hein c'est fou dessert du même
genre se retrouve un peu partout dans le
monde on aurait également découvert des
semblables boules de pierres aux USA
dans le Tennessee en Arizona en
Californie et dans l'Ohio elles ont
toutes des structures sédimentaires
complètement différentes qui n'ont rien
à voir avec les boules de Dickies ça se
voit très bien sur je veux dire elles
sont de couleur différente de
compositions différentes c'est pas la
même roche qui les faits celle-là elles
sont arcs d'ajarchéologiques celle là
elles sont probablement vieilles
plusieurs millions d'années
celle de mohaira qui tiens on n'a pas
regardé de quand elle date
c'est du Paléo saine donc voilà c'est
pas les hautènes on est sur du 50
millions d'années en tour de 50 à 60
millions d'années donc c'est pas du tout
le même âge que c'est rocher là
là on a Sam
osmona Guiche le découvreur d'édits
pyramides de Bosnie a Visoko ah
on nage on injecte de la pyramide de
Bosnie dans le mix maintenant Irina
vient nous aider sur la photo la méga
sphère la plus grande boule de Pierre
des terres jusqu'à présent dans le parc
des pierres des sphères près de zavie
dovitchi les hypothèses ne manquent pas
sur ces sphères mystérieuses
les sites où on les trouve sont en
nombre suffisant pour se contenter
d'explications plus ou moins hasardeuses
certains ont parlé de l'oeuvre
d'extraterrestre dépendent de dinosaures
ou encore des vestiges d'anciennes
civilisations dotés de technologie
inconnues tous ces gens sont des idiots
bien entendu que ce sont des graines
d'arbres géantes
voyez bien voyez bien que cette sphère
de Bosnie vu sa taille comparée à ce
monsieur à absolument tout avoir avec
avec des arbres dont les branches
faisaient cette taille-là voilà
évidemment ça a tout à voir
vous imaginez bien qu'un arbre de 6 km
devait faire des graines qui faisaient
juste la taille de quoi ça fait même pas
un mètre un mètre et demi ça fait même
pas un mètre et demi de rayon ça
d'où elle sort la logique elle est c'est
quoi la logique derrière ça
donc voilà le les gens qui disent que
c'est des pompes de dinosaures des
pompes d'extraterrestres ou des
civilisations inconnues mais ce jour-là
ce sont des idiots évidemment c'est moi
qui ai raison c'est moi et ma théorie
des arbres géants qui a raison
évidemment en réalité les archéologues
ne parviennent pas à expliquer leur
provenance c'est en même temps si tu
demandes à un archéologue de t'expliquer
une formation géologique évidemment tu
vas te
évidemment que tu vas te torter un petit
problème de compétences les archéologues
c'est pas vraiment leur boulot de
comprendre l'origine des formations
géologiques alors
selon le chercheur et journaliste
américain joke joke double day
l'archéologie serait même passé à côté
de la découverte la plus étonnante de la
décennie une méga sphère trouvée en
Bosnie d'un poids estimé de 37 tonnes
encastrées dans la terre c'est un une
fois de plus c'est du nodule
des structures sphériques on a rencontré
absolument tout le temps partout dans
toutes les formations géologiques de
toutes les tailles de toutes les
couleurs de toutes les compositions
chimiques
ne pas savoir la possibilité de
l'existence de ce qu'est un nodule et
encore une fois vous appelez ça une
sphère parfaite vous n'envoyez même pas
la moitié de vous servez que c'est
sphérique ce truc là oui la partie qui
sort à l'air sphérique mais elle en a
juste l'air n'avait aucune idée de ce
qui se trouve en dessous comment
pouvez-vous affirmer qu'il s'agit d'une
sphère
il prétend qu'elles ne sont pas
d'origine naturelle mais qu'il s'agirait
plutôt d'une construction artificielle
laisse faire son constituées d'un
matériau différent de celui des pierres
classiques environnantes la définition
même d'un nodule 9 éléments sont
exactement les mêmes dans les cas des
boules de pierre et de la pierre
naturelle mais étonnamment mais
étonnamment nous faire remarquer le
docteur
haussmannique ces boules de Pierre n'ont
pas de dioxyde de silicium elles sont
elles ont deux autres éléments à la
place là et le manganèse le manganèse
que nous utilisons aujourd'hui pour
donner la dureté à la matière et le
deuxième est le carbonate de calcium
et tu essayes donc de m'impressionner
avec une structure géologique en
carbonate de calcium
c'est avec ça que tu essayes de
m'impressionner tu es en train d'essayer
en plus il est il est teubé parce que il
dit c'est pas logique il dit qu'il y a
de la il y a pas de silice dans leur
sphère elles sont faites en carbonate de
calcium or elles sont censées avoir été
produites à la même époque et par le
même arbre que c'est branches silifié
donc en toute logique elles auraient dû
se focaliser de la même façon
c'est-à-dire en ce siliciant or il vient
de se tirer une énorme balle dans le
pied en nous disant qu'il y a pas de
silice à l'intérieur bien joué
bien joué tu viens encore de te
contredire c'est dommage
Sam haussmannagui en a déduit que cette
chimie incompréhensible de cette chimie
absolument incompréhensible voyons du
carbonate de calcium
même pas voyons un nodule en carbonate
de calcium mais ça n'existe pas voyons
[Rires]
je vois pas où vous allez chercher tout
ça je veux dire une formation géologique
en carbonate de calcium vous n'imaginez
bien que ça n'existe pas voyons
en vertu de quoi
la totalité du bassin de Paris et en
carbonate de calcium mec
Paris tout entier est construite sur et
avec du carbonate de calcium là toutes
les pierres de ces immeubles de ces
immeubles
comment du de l'époque napoléonienne
toutes les cathédrales les tout est fait
en carbonate de calcium
[Rires]
vous êtes des malades vous êtes des
malades
voyons des rochers en carbonate de
calcium mais vous n'imaginez pas c'est
une c'est un possible
la totalité du bassin de Paris là les
cocos c'est tout fait en roches faites
de coccolithophoridés c'est tout du
carbonnade de calcium les mecs vous êtes
fous vous êtes fous
selon lui pour former cette sphère il a
fallu que quelqu'un ajoute
artificiellement des additifs à la
pierre naturelle pour la maintenir en
état de fusion afin de la couler dans
les moules et ainsi obtenir cette forme
sphérique problème où sont passés les
moules
titre titre
sans passer les moules le nouveau film
de Rocco Siffredi et puis en quelle
matière ces moules auraient-ils été
conçu
que c'est pas l'argument le plus évident
pour dire que c'est se faire ne sont pas
d'origine artificielle mais pourquoi pas
mais bon après tout au moins on est
d'accord sur une chose oui non cette
théorie là c'est des conneries
effectivement
pour ça mosmanogeek aucun août ce sont
les habitants d'une autre planète qui
ont fabriqué dans notre préhistoire ces
boules de pierres afin de
j'ai eu le temps de consulter ses rêves
de traverser des millions
d'années-lumière juste pour venir
démouler des pierres chez nous ouais
alors que faire une sphère en carbonate
de calcium c'est impossible si vous la
faites pas fondre c'est impossible de
tailler une pierre en rond c'est pas
possible c'est trop compliqué
j'ai eu le temps de consulter ses
rapports d'expertise et l'étude du
laboratoire ah bah tiens pour une fois
tu t'es référé à de la littérature
scientifique c'est bien ça en examinant
les commentaires sur ces pages Internet
ah j'ai découvert qu'une seule personne
partagée mes convictions alors quand tu
découvres qu'il y a qu'une seule autre
personne au monde qui partage tes
convictions
c'est mauvais signe
c'est très très mauvais signe ça veut
dire que par définition tous les autres
gens qui se sont pensés chez sur le
sujet
y compris des gens beaucoup plus
compétents que toi
sont arrivés à d'autres conclusions
c'est pas une bonne nouvelle c'est
absolument pas une bonne nouvelle c'est
pas un truc que tu annonces comme ça
fièrement ah bah il y a qu'une seule
autre personne au monde qui est d'accord
avec moi c'est c'est juste un grade au
dessus du ah vous voyez je suis un génie
incompris je suis seul à avoir compris
la vérité non non c'est pas une bonne
nouvelle d'être le seul à avoir compris
la vérité c'est une très mauvaise
nouvelle ça veut dire que basiquement
tout le monde tous les gens qui sont
penchés sur le sujet sont pas d'accord
avec toi et que donc il y a une très
très haute probabilité que tu racontes
de la merde
Hassan body ingénieur dans l'énergie
électrique est le premier à avoir
formulé de façon scientifique
l'hypothèse que ces pierres sphériques
de Bosnie sont en réalité des noyaux de
fruits issus de la préhistoire qui se
sont fossilisés la composition des
matières s'est transmuter chimiquement
par un phénomène d'électrolyse
mais pourquoi tu vas chercher un
phénomène d'électrolyse il suffit de
dire que ça c'est faux cilisé espèce de
puisque ça c'est fossilisé pourquoi tu
vas chercher de l'électrolyse enfin
cette opération ne peut qu'intervenir
sous vide bah oui
sans oxygène l'hydrogène traverse la
matière et se lier aux autres matières
c'est ce qu'il a pu constater lors
d'expérience cela implique en tout cas
la transformation de la matière
organique mais pourquoi tu vas chercher
un phénomène d'électrolyse sans oxygène
avec l'hydrogène machin électrolyse sous
vide dis juste que ça c'est faux cilisé
enfin arrête d'aller chercher plus
d'explications bullshit à des trucs que
tu peux expliquer tout simplement je
vais quand même pas vous apprendre à
broder des théories à la con quand même
si il faut vraiment que je vous explique
comment faire des théories à la con
j'ai pris contact avec ce chercheur qui
m'a fait remarquer que le résultat des
études et expertise des matières de
Samos manovic haussmannagik
conclusion enfin
nous n'en sommes qu'au début de nos
recherches
et bah c'est mal parti
en effet répertorié pour l'instant
qu'une partie de notre quête du
gigantisme de nombreux autres édifices
sont encore présentes et elles sont ils
reparle d'édifice mais les buildings
dont il parlait tout au début qui
faisaient l'objet de son introduction
tout ça on en a rien vu au final
enfin on est d'accord qu'à la base
c'était hors sujet de toute façon mais
vu que c'était censé être sur les arbres
géants mais les édifices dont il parle
il n'existe pas ces édifices mais ne
nous les a pas montrés donc de quoi tu
parles de nombreux autres édifices sont
encore présentés aujourd'hui comme des
ouvrages de merde nature nous exposerons
prochainement d'autres éléments allant
dans le sens de notre hypothèse nous
continuerons avec le biais de
confirmation n'est-ce pas le chercheur
américain Elder Ning qui a étudié les
phénomènes sur le gigantisme je vais
vous dire le sérieux du gars nous
rapporte que suivant ces calculs et
études il apparaîtrait que la terre fut
autrefois habité par des géants de 100
mètres de hauteur
pour le chercheur de vérité les géants
ne sont décidément pas que du folklore
issu des mythes et légendes mais d'un
monde antérieur bien réel tenu dans
l'ignorance et oubliée et pas fossilisé
et n'ayant laissé aucune preuve tangible
à part des trucs que vous interprétez de
travers et qui défie absolument tout est
loi de la physique de la gravité et de
la logique la plus élémentaire oui
mesdames et messieurs
voilà voilà c'était la belle et grande
Histoire des arbres géants je
m'attendais pas à souffrir à ce point-là
je pensais qu'on allait rigoler je
pensais que ce serait simple je penserai
qu'après le petit débannage rapide en
disant ça c'est pas un arbre c'est juste
des orgues basaltiques c'est un
phénomène qu'on connaît je pensais qu'on
s'en serait sorti avec ça et bah non
voilà ça a été long ça a été dur titre à
la prochaine fois